ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BACKER
FORGES BRADFORD CABALLERO
QUARTET V. DODD TORONTO EGGMAN
GLAZER GONZALEZ DROVE. HERTZBERG
WEST SO- TADO JONES KAMLAGER
LAYERED LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
CHART BOTH PAN PORTANTINO. OFF
RUBIO INNER STERN I'M WHITE
HOUSE SKI WIENER WELL. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS TO BE ON
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE WILL READ LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. BY SENATOR HER TITLE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
GOD OF MERCY AND COMPASSION WE
PRAY THIS PRAYER FOR EACH OTHER
. MAY YOUR MEAT MERCY EACH DAY
IN LIGHT OF YOUR OWN HEART AT
THE HANDS OF YOUR LOVED ONES IN
THE EYESOF A STRANGER AND THE
NEEDY. AND IF BY CHANCE YOU DO
NOT AT FIRST MEET THIS MERCY
THEN SEARCH YOUR HEART FOR IT
LISTEN PATIENTLY FOR WORD OF IT.
AND IT WILL TAP YOU ON THE
SHOULDER A QUIET SURPRISE A
SMALL GESTURE THE TENDER LOOK
GIVEN AND RECEIVED IN THE
ENCOUNTERS OF YOUR DAY. COMMENT. COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME FOR
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. THANK
YOU AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY. PLEASE
ENTER HE'S WHICH IT STANDS ONE
NATION UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATORS
BATES AND DOLLY PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME SENATORS. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES THIS IS THE TIME TO
REMOVE BILLS FROM THE INACTIVE
FILED. TODAY IS THAT TIME LIMIT
. SENATOR GONZALEZ. YES I THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM A THIRTEEN SB
THREE FORTY TWO FROM THE NECK TO
FILE ORDERED. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE. THE BILL
MOVED FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
SINGMAN WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MEMBERS ARE GONNA START IN
ON THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE SECOND READING FILE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTEEN. THANK
YOU SENATE THIRD READING MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO START WITH. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX SENATOR
ALAN. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT TO BY SENATOR ALAN AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC HOUSING
PROJECTS SENATOR ALAN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THIS CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
PLACES A MEASURE ON A FUTURE
STATEWIDE BALLOT. ASKING VOTERS
TO REPEAL ARTICLE THIRTY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA. CONSTITUTION NOW
PROVED IN- EIGHT NINETEEN FIFTY
BY VOTERS ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR
REQUIRES MAJORITY APPROVAL BY
THE VOTERS OF THE CITY OR COUNTY
TO DEVELOP CONSTRUCT. OR ACQUIRE
A PUBLICLY FUNDED LOW RENT
HOUSING PROJECTS. CALIFORNIA HAS
TWENTY TWO AFFORDABLE AND
AVAILABLE RENTAL HOMES FOR EVERY
ONE HUNDRED EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. NEARLY 40% OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVE NEAR OR BELOW
THE POVERTY LINE A MAJORITY OF
OUR STATES RENTER'S SPENT MORE
THAN 30% OF THEIR INCOME. ON
HOUSING NEARLY ONE THIRD SPEND
MORE THAN HALF. TOO MANY PEOPLE
ARE ONE MISSED PAYCHECK AWAY
FROM HOMELESSNESS. NO THE SEVEN
DECADES SINCE ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR WAS ESTABLISHED
CALIFORNIA'S VOTERS OF TIME AND
AGAIN MADE IT CLEAR THEY WANT
THEIR LEADERS TO DO BETTER. BY
THOSE WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO
AFFORD HOUSING SUPPORTING BALLOT
MEASURES THAT DEDICATE HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF. TAXPAYER DOLLARS
TO TACKLING THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. CRISIS AT THE
STATE OWES IT TO ALL TAXPAYERS
TO USE THE MONEY AS EFFICIENTLY
AS POSSIBLE- I CA EXPERIENCE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT EACH
COMMITTEE HAS NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SENATOR WIENER. I THANK
YOU- BROWN PRESIDENT I AM A
PROUD I JOIN AUTHOR OF A CA TO-
AND I'M THRILLED THAT WE- I HOPE
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD- TODAY THIS
IS SO LONG OVERDUE- THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT IS AN
ABSOLUTE SCAR ON THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION- THE END CAME
DURING A VERY UGLY TIME PERIOD
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY IN TERMS
OF EFFORTS TO END SEGREGATION
AND- BACKLASH- AGAINST- THOSE
EFFORTS- AND IT'S SO PERNICIOUS
BECAUSE- ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR. IT
SINGLES OUT ONLY ONE KIND OF
HOUSING. FOR MANDATORY-
REPLACEMENT BEFORE THE VOTERS ON
ELECTION. DOESN'T SAY ALL
HOUSING ONLY ONE KIND OF HOUSING
IS SUBJECT. TO THIS SIGNIFICANT-
HURDLE- AND THAT IS HOUSING.
THAT IS A PUBLICLY FUNDED. TO
MAKE SURE THAT LOW INCOME PEOPLE
HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS.
AND THE ADDRESSES OF WHY WOULD
WE SINGLE OUT ONLY THAT KIND OF
HOUSING AND I THINK IT ANSWERS
ITSELF. WAS DESIGNED TO
PERPETUATE SEGREGATION BY INCOME
BY CLASS OF CETERA THIS SHOULD
NOT BE IN OUR CONSTITUTION IT IS
A TERRIBLE SCARRING ON OUR
CONSTITUTION AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S TIME TO GET RID
OF IT- AND THERE IS AN AYE VOTE
. BETTER TO LETTER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. A. TO I
THINK THAT IT IS ABOUT TIME THAT
WE ALL REALIZE THAT IF WE'RE
GOING TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE
HOUSING THE HOUSING SHORTAGE IT
IS TO CHANGE THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT ARE BEFORE US
IT IS BECOMING- PRETTY EVIDENT
THAT IF WE DON'T ACT GOD KNOWS
WHEN CAN WE ACT AND I APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR. TO TAKE US FORWARD
CHAU IN TURN WE COULD START
BRINGING AFFORDABILITY INTO
CALIFORNIA MORE HOUSING IS
DEFINITELY DESPERATELY NEEDED SO
I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND EVERYONE WHO
SUPPORTS THIS BILL AND I THINK
IT IS THE RIGHT TIME RIGHT PLACE
AND WE SHOULD BE PART OF IT AND
LET'S MAKE HISTORY TOGETHER. I
URGE TO VOTE THANK YOU MATTER.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN CENTER ALLEN YOU
MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU I WANT
TO I WANT TO JUST POINT OUT THE
CREDIBLE COALITION OF SUPPORTERS
OF EVERYONE FROM THE REALTORS TO
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY I THINK IT'S FOLKS
COMING FROM ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
RECOGNIZING THAT WE NEED TO MOVE
ON THIS. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA FIVE
ATKINS AYE BAKER. FIVE FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO HIGH
COURT HEAVY. I DON. THE RAZA I
EGGMAN. GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
FIVE GROWTH FIVE HERTZBERG I
LISTEN I HER TADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE
THE MON I MCGUIRE BYE MELENDEZ.
FIVE MIN AYE NEWMAN I NIELSEN A
SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM. HI
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH I RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN HI NUMBER HI WE
CASTING AYE WIENER. I WILK HI
SENATOR ALLEN MOVE THE CALL
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
AYE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT SENATOR GLAZERS HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. IN ABOUT SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
BY SENATOR GLAZERS AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION SENATOR
GLAZERS THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE I'M- SENATE
BILL SEVENTY FIVE AIMS TO
INCREASE GRADUATION RATES FOR
STUDENTS FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. THE BELL THE
BILL CENTRAL FOCUSES TO IMPROVE
EQUITY FOR ALL STUDENTS. SINCE
FIRST PUT INTO LAW IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM IS
SERVED ALMOST NINETEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS THAT PARTICIPATED
CSU'S. THE STUDENTS RECEIVE
PRIORITY REGISTRATION AND
ADVANCED ADVISING TOOLS NEEDED
TO HELP STUDENTS GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS OR TWO YEARS IF THEY
WERE TRANSFERRING FROM A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. MORE THAN
TWO THIRDS OF STUDENTS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PROGRAM OR
PELL RECIPIENTS. ACCORDING TO
DATA PROVIDED BY THE CSU ABOUT
HALF OF THOSE. WHO ARE
PARTICIPANTS ARE FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS.
MEMBERS IMPROVING EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS IS
ESSENTIAL TO GENERATE UPWARD
ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND ENSURE A
PROSPEROUS STATE. THIS BILL
TARGETS THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM THE FIRST GENERATION LOW
INCOME AND UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS. PUTTING THE STUDENTS
ON A PATH TO GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BAKER ARE YOU FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM FIVE
PROTESTING AYE DODD. TORONTO I
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I HERTZBERG AYE WESTERN.
I FURTADO AYE JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA I LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION
I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE A TO A
VOTE. I CAN. I PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER. FIVE
STERN AYE NUMBER I WANT CASTING
AYE WIENER. I WELL HI SENATOR
GLAZERS MUSICAL. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY NINE SENATOR
GLAZERS IS READY PLEASE PLEASE
CALL OF THE- PLEASE. PLEASE READ
THE BILL. SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT FIVE BY SENATOR GLAZER
AN ACT RELATING TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
SENATOR GLAZERS THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS. S. C. A. FIVE WOULD
INCREASE THE VOTING RIGHTS OF
THE STUDENT MEMBERS OF THE UC
BOARD OF REGENTS BY ALLOWING THE
EXISTING NON VOTING STUDENT
REGENT. TO RECEIVE VOTING POWER
GIVING BOTH STUDENTS THAT VOTING
RIGHTS- THIS LET THIS MEASURE
WOULD ONLY TAKE PLACE IF
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. CURRENTLY THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION REQUIRES
THAT YOU SEE BE ADMINISTERED BY
A BOARD OF REGENTS MADE UP OF
TWENTY FIVE MEMBERS SEVEN EX
OFFICIO EIGHTEEN APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR CONFIRMED BY THE
SENATE. IN ADDITION THE UC BOARD
OF REGENTS HAVE APPOINTED TO
STUDENT REGENTS TO THE BOARD BUT
ONLY ONE. WITH VOTING POWER.
THIS BILL WOULD BEST BOTH
STUDENTS WITH A VOTE AT THE
BOARD AND ALLOW THE STUDENT
REGION TO VOTE FROMTHE
BEGINNING OF THEIR TERM. THIS
BILL HAS NO RECEIVE NO
OPPOSITION I WANT TO THANK CO
AUTHORS FROM HERE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR FROM SALINAS
SENATOR FROM BERKELEY IN THE
SENATOR FRIST HANNAH FOR THEIR
CO SPONSORSHIP WITH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THING MAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BAKER I PORCHES AYE BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO HI AYE PROTESTING. I
DON DERISIVE FIVE EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH
. I HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. I HER
TADO I JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA I LIMÓN AYE
MCGUIRE. FIVE MELENDEZ FIVE MIN
AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE
TELEVOTE AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE
STERN AYE NUMBER HI MY COUNTY I
WIENER AYE WILK HI SENATOR
GLAZERS MOVE THE CALL MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
SENATOR HER TADO IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR HER TADO RELATIVE TO
ROSEANNE DO WHICH RECOGNITION
DAY CENTER WHO TAUGHT OF THE
FORGERS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING. I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT A C. R. SIXTY
THREE RESOLUTION THAT RECOGNIZES
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH AS ROSE
AND WHICH DAY. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS THE PLACE THAT IS NOT
REALLY KNOWN AS BEING THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE REGION IN THE STATE
BUT IT IS IT IS HOME NOT ONLY TO
THE YOUNGEST WOMAN LIKE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE IS ALSO
HOME TO THE FIRST WOMAN ELECTED.
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SENATOR BREACH WAS THE DAUGHTER
OF SERBIAN IMMIGRANTS HAILING
FROM THE SMALL TOWN OF DINUBA.
HE SERVED SIXTEEN YEARS IN THE
SENATE AND RETIRED IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO. DURING HER TIME
CENTER WHICH SERVES NOT ONLY AS
THE ONLY WOMAN FOR TWO YEARS.
BUT SHE ALSO SERVED OF THE
SENATE SPAM OF CONSCIENCE. HE
REFUSE TO BE IGNORED. MANY OF
YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH HER BOW
SOMETHING SIMILAR TO THIS ONE
HERE. BELLS ARE DIFFICULT TO
FIND IN STORES THESE DAYS BUT I
WAS FORTUNATE TO FIND THIS ONE.
THIS BALLS FORWARD FROM THE FROM
THE FAMILY MRS LINDA LEE SHARES
RIGHT WELL. OF HANFORD BORN IN
NINETEEN FORTY TWO I WANT TO
READ WITH YOUR PERMISSION I'M
PRESENT I LIKE TO BRING IT.
PERMISSION GIVEN THANK YOU. IT
IS SAID THAT WHENEVER HER
COLLEAGUES ADDRESS THE GENTLEMAN
OF THE SENATE SHE WOULD RING HER
BELL TO REMIND THEM THAT THERE
WAS A WOMAN PRESENT. IT IS
BECAUSE OF HER THAT WE ALSO HAVE
A WOMAN'S RESTROOM OFF OF THE
SENATE FLOOR. THE ORIGINAL PLANS
OF THE CAPITAL RICHER FOR DID
NOT INCLUDE THE WOMEN'S
RESTROOM. ONE WAS ADDED AFTER
HER ELECTION. THE RUSSIAN
MISSILE KNOWN AS THE ROSE. ROOM
RULES AND WHICH WAS ALSO AN
ADVOCATE FOR AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY. STORIES OF HER
BRINGING IN FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
ONLY TO WITHHOLD FROM HUNGRY
COOPER UNTIL SHE WAS ABLE TO
MAKE A POINT ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE ARE SOMEWHAT
LEGENDARY. MANY OF US HERE IN
THE SENATE WOULD NOT BE HERE HAD
ROSE AND WHICH NOT BROKEN SO
MANY BARRIERS AND LEAD THE WAY
FOR WOMEN TO SERVE IN THE
SENATE. THE BALLOT DIFFICULT
REMINDER OF THE MANY STRUGGLES
WOMEN FACE BUT ALSO AN
INSPIRATION. TO CONTINUE
SPEAKING EVEN WHEN YOU FEEL ON
HER. BECAUSE OF THIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE TO
RECOGNIZE JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH
AS ROSE AND WHICH DAY THANK YOU
. SENATOR NELSON. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF SERVING WITH ROSEANNE DOING.
I CAME HERE FOUR YEARS AFTER SHE
DID. SHE BLAMES THE TRAIL. AND
WHO MIGHT HAVE THOUGHT THAT A
WOMAN. FROM A VERY SMALL SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY TOWN. WOULD
BECOME THE FIRST WOMAN. TO BE IN
THE S. STATE SENATOR IN
CALIFORNIA. ROSEANNE DID
COMMENDABLY. I WOULDN'T SAY SHE
HAD ROUGH EDGES BUT SHE WAS FIRM
IN HER CONVICTION. AND OUR
PATIENTS AND ASSERTING HER
MEMBERSHIP IN THIS HOUSE AS A
FULL MEMBER. THE BILL THAT MY
SAYING YOU'RE CALLING HERE. VERY
TOOL TOWARDS THOSE AND A BIT OF
MUSIC TO. AND ROSEANNE WAS
FIERCE IN FIGHTING FOR WHAT SHE
BELIEVED IN. I PREFER CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. WE TEAMED UP WHEN
WE HAD THE MIDLIFE CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ROSE AT AN IDEA
THEY- THING THAT WAS KIND OF A
WITH THE TIME. GOVERNOR BROWN
WITH HIM MAKE UP HIS MIND
WHETHER TO INITIATE AERIAL
APPLICATION OF MALATHION DATE TO
READ TO KEEP THIS. REGIS PASSED. SO WE THOUGHT LOWS IN IDA B.
WELLS FOR US TO TALK TO HIM
ABOUT IT IN ADVANCE. TO A CALL
DOWN THERE SAID HE WAS TOO BUSY
. WE MARCH DOWN TO THAT OFFICE.
HARD HARD BENCHES WERE STILL
THERE AT THE TIME. SENATORS DO
YOU HAVE AN APPOINTMENT NO BUT
WE'RE GOING TO STAY HERE UNTIL
WE- GET TO SEE THE GOVERNOR.
WHICH WE DID I THINK IT WAS
ABOUT FORTY MINUTES. AND HE
SUMMONED HIS SECRETARY OF
AGRICULTURE OVER AND ROSEANNE HE
AND I. SAID ON THE FRANK
DISCUSSION. ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE WAS WORTH
BEING SAVED. ROSEANNE ALWAYS
FOUGHT FOR THAT ALWAYS KNEW THAT
IT DESERVES SAY. YOU STILL GET
TO ENJOY THE ROSE ROOM HERE.
THERE ARE SO MANY TRADITIONS
WITH ROSE AND BROUGHT TO THIS
HOUSE SO MUCH DIG. AND SHE
SURELY WAS ONE- WOULD BE
RESPECTED IN ANY COUNCIL. SMALL
DINUBA OR THE LARGE CITIES THE
REST OF THE STATE. I TAKE OVER
OFF SPINNER BROTHER WILLIE. WHO
IS YOUR CONSTANT COMPANION.
HELPING HER. GET AROUND MOVE
BACK AND FORTH FROM DINUBA. I
WILL MEASURE I HAVE MISTER. BUT
SHE HAS BROUGHT DIGNITY TO THE
SENATE IN THIS WELL THAT WE
SHOULD CONSTANTLY REMEMBER.
SANTA ROSA AND WILL H. THE DINER. SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUES FOR
PUTTING THIS FORWARD AND GIVING
US THE ABILITY TO GIVE THE
RECOGNITION TO OUR FIRST FEMALE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR ROSE
AND WHICH AND- I WANTED TO-
INDICATE THAT I'M VERY GLAD.
THAT OR CALLING MADE THE POINTS
ABOUT WHY OR- YOU KNOW WHY DO WE
HAVE A BATHROOM NAMED AFTER THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ONE BECAUSE WHEN
SHE STARTED THERE WERE NO FEMALE
RESTAURANTS. NOW WE KNOW THE
BATHROOMS ARE CENTRAL AND WE AND
THERE SHOULD NEVER BE A
SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE DOES NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO THEM BUT I HOPE.
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THE
REDESIGN OF THIS BUILDING THAT
WE THINK ABOUT ADDITIONAL WAYS
TO HONOR IMPORTANT WOMEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE AS WE LOOK
AROUND THIS BUILDING WE SEE THAT
A NUMBER OF ROOMS. OTHER THAN
BATHROOMS ARE NAMED AFTER
PROMINENT MEN IN THE LEGISLATURE
BUT NOT ANY OF OUR PROMINENT
WOMEN'S SELF I SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION I'M GLAD IT'S BEING
BROUGHT FORWARD BUT I THINK WE
ALSO CAN DO BETTER AS WE
RECOGNIZE AN HONOR IMPORTANT
WOMEN. IN THE LEGISLATURE. FOR
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SAYING NINE
SENATOR HURTADO YOU MAY CONCLUDE
. THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER
FIVE FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM I COURTESY AYE DODD
. DURACELL I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG I WESTERN. HI FURTADO
I JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA I LIMON HI MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN AYE A CELLO BOTH. PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE HI
I WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE
WILK AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DODD A CHAU BUG I. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NOES ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY ONE SENATOR
BRADFORD. ARE YOU PREPARED YES
PLEASE PLEASE READ THE BILL.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING
TO CRIMINAL GANGS CENTER
BRADFORD THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT SIMPLY
ADDS AN ADDITIONAL MEMBER TO THE
CAL DATABASE. AS A TECHNICAL
THROUGH THE TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. AS WELL NO THE GANG
CAL GANG DATABASES MAINTAINED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
USED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE TO STORE THE
NAMES OF OVER FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE SUSPECTED. OF
BEING ACTIVE GANG MEMBERS ARE
POSSIBLY ASSOCIATED WITH A GAME
HOWEVER OUR RECENT AUDIT HAS
FOUND THE DATABASE HAS A LOT
ENACT. AND INADEQUATE- LOCK AND
WITH OVERSIGHT THAT'S RESULTED
IN A LOT OF UNRELIABLE AND
POTENTIALLY VIOLATING. ONE'S
PRIVACY RIGHTS- BASED ON THE
STATE DATABASE THIS RESULTED IN
QUESTIONABLE ENTRIES AND
INCLUSION OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
NO GANG AFFILIATION INCLUDING
CHILDREN SENIORS AND SADLY ALL
TOO OFTEN AKRON AMERICANS AND
LATINOS. I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THAT WE KNOW THERE ARE PLENTY
HANGAL GANG MEMBERS WE'VE SEEN
PLENTY OF THEM OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS. THIS RESULTED IN
QUESTIONABLE ENTRIES AGAIN THE
REVIEW- LET ME MOVE ON BUT THE
GAME DATABASE ALLOWS FOR
INDIVIDUAL TO REQUEST THE
REMOVAL OF THE DATABASE AFTER
RECEIVING NOTICE FROM LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. BETWEEN
OCTOBER NINETEENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FORTY REQUEST A REMOVAL
WERE MADE AND ONLY TEN WERE
GRANTED. UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS OFTEN CHOOSE
NOT TO PURSUE THIS BECAUSE OF
THE COSTLY- ME TOO COSTLY TIME
CONSUMING THIS BILL WILL SIMPLY
JUST ADD AN ATTORNEY WITH
CONTESTING AND INDIVIDUALS
DESIGNATION AS A GANG MEMBER TO
THE KING- GAME DATABASE. AND
IT'S ALSO INCLUDING- THIS
REPRESENTATION WILL HELP ENSURE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE DATABASE AS
WELL AS STRENGTHENED COMMUNITY
TRUST IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PROTECT INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES IRIS THE BEING
INAPPROPRIATELY LABELED AS BEING
AFFILIATED. THIS BILL SHOULD BE
THE BEGINNING OF A LARGER
CONVERSATION WE HAVE ABOUT THE
CAL GATE DATABASE SYSTEM WHICH
IS CURRENTLY ON FEAR AND AGAIN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS BLACK
AND BROWN INDIVIDUALS. HI I HAVE
RECENTLY BEEN MADE AWARE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OPPOSITIONS'S BILL
AND WILL BE WORKING TO TRY TO
ADJUST SOME THE CONCERNS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. THIRTY NIELSEN. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE I DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THIS
IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT THEY BE
TOTALLY INVOLVED. I AM
UNSYMPATHETIC AND I WILL VOTE NO
TODAY. THE BILL MAY DEVELOP INTO
A FORM THAT I COULD ACCEPT IN
THE FUTURE. BUT I SUBMIT THIS IS
RATHER ON TIME. GANGS RUN
RAMPANT ACROSS AMERICA TODAY
POURING ACROSS OUR BORDER. OUR
COUNTRY. RAVAGING AND PILLAGING
. TERRIBLE SITUATION IN OUR
COMMUNITIES NOT ONLY IN THE
LARGE TOWNS THE BIG CITIES. OVER
TWENTY YEARS AGO THE TINY TOWN
OF HAMILTON CITY. UP IN GLENN
COUNTY WAS TAKEN OVER. BY A
CRIMINAL GANG. A VERY SMALL.
OKAY BUT A VERY SMALL CITY. IT
IS A CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER.
WE BEST BE CAUTIOUS. FOR THAT
PURPOSE I WILL VOTE NO. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN SENATOR BRADFORD YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU IN A
PRESIDENT AND WE ALL SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT GANG ACTIVITY AS
WE STATED WE'VE SEEN IT RUNNING
RAMPANT OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
WHAT WE SAW JANUARY SIX YOU CAN
CLEARLY. CATEGORIZED AS DANCE
BUT SURPRISINGLY NONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS FIND THEIR NAMES ON
GAME DATABASES AGAIN WE SHOULD
BE JUST AS CONCERNED OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO CONTINUE TO FIND
THEIR NAMES ON GANG DATABASES
WHEN IT'S A LOT LATER PROVED
THEY'RE NOT GAINING MEMBERS THEY
SIMPLY LIVED IN THE WRONG
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
WRONG INDIVIDUALS OR HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
ASSOCIATED WITH GANGS THIS IS A
SENSE MEASURE AND IT'S SIMPLY
ADDS A TURN WHO HAS A WILL OF
THE AND ABOUT IN. WHO ARE GAY
CONTROL AND I WAS ASK YOUR I. GO. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CORTES
HE I DODD TORONTO I. AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER TADO
NO JONES. KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA I LIMON I MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE
I MELENDEZ NO MAN. NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN NO A CHOI VOTE PAN. I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE NUMBER ALL
RIGHT HI QUITE COSTLY I WIENER.
WELL NOW. FOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES NO DODD
JONES. MANY A TROUBLED. ROTH
WIENER I. FIVE TWENTY SIX NO ICE
TWENTY SEVEN NO SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY THREE SENATOR DIMOND SHE
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIX THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR
LIMÓN AN ACT RELATING TO
CONTRACTS SENATE HIM ON THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM%
PRESIDENT SB SIXTY THREE
REQUIRES THE DISCLOSURE IS GIVEN
TO NON ENGLISH SPEAKING CO
SIGNERS THIS NOTICE WILL BE
TRANSLATED AND AVAILABLE ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
WEBSITE. THE DISCLOSURE PROVIDES
NOTICE TO THE COSIGNER THAT THEY
ARE SIGNING A CONTRACT IT IS
ALSO PROTECTS BUSINESSES BY
COMBATING CLAIMS THAT THE
CONTRACT IS UNENFORCEABLE DUE TO
CLOSE AYE ARE NOT BEING AWARE
THAT THERE WAS A CONTRACT. WE
HAVE WORK WITH OPPOSITION AND
HAVE AGREED TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL BE TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I HAVE A- IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BAKER. I PORCHES. BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE FOR TESTING I
DODD DORADO I EGGMAN. I GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO AYE HER TADO. I JONES
. KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA
FIVE THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELENDEZ. MAN I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. NO A CHIRLA BOTH. I PAN
I PORTANTINO HI ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M BURKE I
LIKE HOW SKI I WIENER. I WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORGES DODD GROWTH. JONES
MELENDEZ WILK. I THIRTY ONE
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR PORTANTINO
. HE IS PREPARED PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE AND
ACCORDING TO URGENCY THERE A
SECRET MEDIALLY. CENTER
PORTANTINO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB SIX THIRTY TWO IS AN
URGENCY MEASURE TO APPROPRIATE
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD FOR
THE PAYMENT OF TWO CLAIMS
RELATED TO THE ARONIE S.
CONVICTION OF GEORGE SO THE
WAITERS AND GUY MILES IN EACH OF
THEIR CASES THE COURT SET ASIDE
THE CONVICTIONS AND GRANTED
HABEAS CORPUS RELIEF. THE AG
CONCEDED THAT BOTH MEN A PROVEN
BY A PREPONDERANCE OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY ARE INNOCENT
OF THE CRIMES FOR WHICH THEY
WERE IN PRISON AFTER CONSIDERING
ALL OF THE EVIDENCE ON THE
RECORD THE BOARD APPROVED
COMPENSATION FOR THE TIME THAT
THEY WERE WRONGFULLY IMPRISONED
AND RECOMMENDS AN APPROPRIATION
TO COVER THOSE PAYMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER.
I PORCHES. BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO I PROTECTING AYE DODD
YOU'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROSS.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO
I JONES I KAMLAGER. I LAYERED I
LEYVA HI THE MON FIVE WIRE. I
MELENDEZ. MANY AYE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. I PATROL BOAT I CAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE I'M BURKE HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI AYE WIENER AYE
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. PORGES DODD. GROVE
MELENDEZ. WELL. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. PORCHES DODD.
GROWTH MELENDEZ WELL. FIVE
THIRTY THREE KNOWS THEY'RE ON
THEIR AGENCY FIVE THIRTY THREE
NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE PASSES ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
SENATOR GLAZERS READY READY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TWENTY
ONE BY SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT
RELATING TO VEHICLES SENATOR
GLAZERS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SB TWENTY
ONE WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO APPLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO
SPONSOR A MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS LICENSE PLATE PROGRAM.
LET ME NOTE THAT THE MY PARTNER
IN THIS LEGISLATION IS ARE GOOD
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND THE
FEES FROM THE SPECIALIZED
LICENSE PLATE WILL BE USED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THIS LICENSE
PLATE IS ONE SMALL STEP IN
BRINGING GREATER AWARENESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND GREATER
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT HELP STUDENTS
DEALING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS AND
LET ME MENTION THAT I KNOW OF
MANY MEMBERS ON THIS FLOOR
WORKING VERY HARD TO ENHANCE
OUR- FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
SCHOOLS THIS BILL IS IN NO WAY
MEANT TO. BE ANY KIND OF
SUBSTITUTE FOR THE SUBSTANTIAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE THAT ARE
NEEDED BY THE BILLS PASSED OUT
OF THE TRANSPORTATION AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITHOUT
ANY OPPOSITION AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NINE MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SAYING NO
OBJECTIONS I THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES REFER TO
GO BACK TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY TWO SENATOR RUBIO IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVENTY BY SENATOR RUBIO
AND AFTER RELATED TO
KINDERGARTEN SENATOR RUBIO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SB SEVENTY
AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THAT I'VE WORKED ON
FOR THREE YEARS TO ENSURE THAT
WE GET IT RIGHT. THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN RECEIVE
CRITICAL INSTRUCTION IN THE
EARLIEST YEARS OF LEARNING
SPECIFICALLY SB SEVENTY WILL
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO COMPLETE ONE
YEAR OF KINDERGARTEN PRIOR TO
ENTERING THE FIRST GRADE OF A
PUBLIC ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. TO BE
CLEAR- WE'RE NOT CHANGING THE
COMPULSORY AGE. AS AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TEACHER I HAVE PERSONALLY
WITNESSED HOW EARLY EDUCATION
CAN HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
STUDENT ACADEMIC SUCCESS. YOU
CAN EASILY DISTINGUISH THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BILLS HAVE
BEEN IN CANDOR AND THOSE THAT
HAVE NOT. I HAVE BEEN IN A FIRST
GRADE CLASSROOM WHEN I HAVE TO
STUDENTS THAT ARE THE SAME AGE
HOWEVER. ONE STRUGGLES TO SIT IN
A CLASSROOM SETTING DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH THE PENCIL IS
HOLDING THE BOOK UPSIDE DOWN
BECAUSE THEY'VE NEVER HAD THAT
EXPERIENCE. WELL THE OTHER
STUDENT IS ALREADY READING
SECOND GRADE LEVEL THE WRITING
FULL SENTENCES AND GOING EVEN
FURTHER TALKING ABOUT ALL THE
SCIENCE PROJECTS THAT WORKED ON
DURING THE SUMMER. SO THAT
DISPARITY ONLY GROWS
EXPONENTIALLY AS THE CHILDREN GO
UP IN GREAT LEVELS. NOW MORE
THAN EVER WE MUST SUPPORT OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS BY ENSURING
THAT THEY RECEIVE THOSE CRITICAL
INSTRUCTION EARLY ON WHICH IS
THE BUILDING BLOCKS FOR LATER
YEARS. FOR STUDENTS WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN ENROLLED IN KINDERGARTEN
OFTENTIMES IT'S THE TEACHERS AND
THE PARENTS WHO ARE SPENDING SO
MUCH TIME. TRYING TO TEACH THEM
THE FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS THAT
THEIR OTHER PEERS HAVE ALREADY
MASTERED IN KINDERGARTEN.
ADDITIONALLY OUR TEACHERS
STRUGGLE NOW MORE THAN EVER US
WE KNOW AND THE BEST WAY WE CAN
SUPPORT THEM IS BY HAVING
STUDENTS PREPARED. IN CLASS AND
AS THEY MOVE UP IN ACADEMIC RATE
LEVELS AGAIN AS A TEACHER I CAN
ATTEST THAT WE- OFTEN HAVE THREE
TO FOUR LEVELS GOING ON IN ONE
CLASSROOM. AND HAVING TWO
DIFFERENT DIFFERENTIATE AND
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
CHILD LEARNS IS A CHALLENGE WE
DO IT WE DO IT GLADLY. BUT WE
NEED TO SUPPORT OUR TEACHERS
STUDENTS CANNOT AFFORD THE GAP
THAT INCREASES. EXPONENTIALLY AS
I STATED AND THIS IS THE TIME
ACROSS THE STATE WE HAVE SEEN
LARGE DROPS IN SCHOOL
ENROLLMENT. AND AS WE KNOW COVE
IT HAS NOW MADE IT WORSE. LAST
YEAR THE C. D. E. RELEASED DATA
HIGHLIGHTING AN ENROLLMENT DROP.
OF ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA'S K. TO TWELVE
EDUCATION. AND IT'S ALSO BEEN
REPORTED. THAT THERE IS A DROP
IN KINDERGARTEN SPECIFICALLY OF
SIXTY ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS AND
THAT IS VERY SIGNIFICANT FOR
EXAMPLE KINDERGARTEN ENROLLMENT
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ACADEMIC SCHOOL YEAR FOR LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
DECLINED 14% THAT IS SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND IN LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS THIS
DECLINE IS ABOUT THREE TIMES
LARGER IN RECENT YEARS
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ALSO. REPORTED DECLINE
OF SEVENTEEN POINT 6% OAKLAND
UNIFIED 9% DECLINE LONG BEACH
UNIFIED 10% DECLINE AND IT GOES
ON AND ON WE ARE LOSING OUR
CHILDREN AT THE YOUNGER AGES
WHERE THEY NEED IT THE MOST
CLEARLY THESE UPCOMING SCHOOL
YEARS ARE GOING TO BE VERY
CHALLENGING NOT ONLY TO THE
STUDENTS BUT FOR TEACHERS AS
WELL AS THEY WERE SEE A LOT
MORE. DIFFERENCE AMONG THEIR
STUDENTS THE EDUCATIONAL GAP IS
GOING TO BE LARGER WE NEED TO
GIVE EVERY CHILD THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO START OFF WITH AN
EVEN PLAYING FIELD BEFORE I
CLOSE I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT I ADDRESS THE EQUITY ISSUE
THAT SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
BROUGHT UP. THE STATE HAS
INVESTED ADDITIONAL PROGRAMMING
DOLLARS FOR CHILDREN BEFORE AND
AFTER SCHOOL AND THOSE OPTIONS
WILL STILL BE AVAILABLE I'M
CURRENTLY WORKING ON ANOTHER
COMPANION BILL TO ENSURE THAT WE
TACKLE THAT ISSUE EVEN FURTHER I
AM COMMITTED TO WORKING TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
THERESOURCES THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN SCHOOL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU. MEMBERS WANT TO
REMIND YOU THAT IT GETS
DIFFICULT TO HEAR APPEAR WHEN
THERE'S A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
GOING ON SO IF YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION IF YOU COULD
LEAVE THAT. THE CHAMBER SAID BE.
UP MUCH APPRECIATED SENATOR
BRIDGES. THANK YOU BETTER
PRESENT IF I MAY POSE A
QUESTION- THROUGH YOU TO THE
AUTHOR. CENTER RUBIO YOU TAKE A
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- FORMER
GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED. A BILL
LIKE THIS. A NUMBER OF YEARS
BACK. AND FROM WHAT I READ WAS
THAT. GOVERNOR BROWN SAID
THERE'S PLENTY OF OTHER
SUPPLEMENTAL. FORMS OF
EDUCATION. THAT CAN BRING THESE
KIDS UP TO SPEED. NOW I'VE GOT
TO ELEMENTARY SCHOOL BOYS. I
THINK WHAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED
DURING THIS CODE PROCESS
ESPECIALLY. IS THAT. WE NEED
KINDERGARTEN TO BE AN ESSENTIAL
PART. OF THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE. BUT IF YOU FORCE
PEOPLE IN. WHEN THEY'RE NOT HERE
TO A CERTAIN GRADE LEVEL YOU
HAVE A BIFURCATION OF THE
CLASSROOM ITSELF RELEASED THE
CLASS EXPERIENCE SOME KIDS ARE
HAD SOME KEEP SOME KIDS ARE ON
PAR AND SOME KIDS- ARE BEHIND.
IT WHAT HAPPENS IS THE SCHOOL
HAS NO CHOICE BUT ESSENTIALLY TO
APPEAL TO THE INTERMEDIATE AND
THE CHALLENGE ON SECTION OF THE
CLASS FOR PURPOSES OF KEEPING
THAT THE CLASSROOM FUNCTIONING
AS A WHOLE. AND SO I SUPPORT ON
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE MY
ONLY OUR QUESTION IS. TO YOU IS
. IF A PARENT CAN PROVE THAT
THEIR CHILD IS UP TO SPEED. AND
MAYBE IS HOME SCHOOLED OR HAS
RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL EDUCATION
COULD THE BY PASS KINDERGARTEN
WINNER ELIGIBLE FOR FIRST GRADE
. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ABSOLUTELY IN FACT THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT SPEAKS
ABOUT HOME SCHOOLING IN
PARTICULAR WHICH I KNEW WAS AN
ISSUE THAT. OB PEOPLE BROUGHT UP
SO I WORK WITH THE SCHOOL HOME
SCHOOLING- ORGANIZATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT WAS IN THE BILL THAT
THAT IS AN OPTION IF PARENTS
CHOOSE TO HOME SCHOOL THEM. THAT
IS AN OPTION AND THAT IS
ACCEPTABLE TO PROVE THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY RECEIVED THAT ONE YEAR
BEFORE COMING TO SCHOOL THEY CAN
ALSO CHOOSE PRIVATE SCHOOLS NOT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT'S ALSO AN
OPTION. AND THERE'S ALSO
DISCRETION AS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITH PARENTS IF THEY FEEL THAT
THEIR CHILD IS UP TO PAR THEY
CAN GET THEM TESTED AND ALONG
WITH THE PAIN AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT THEY CAN DECIDE. IF
THEY MET THE CRITERIA TO JUST
MOVE ON TO FIRST RATE THEY CAN
DO SO AS WELL GOT INTO IT THIS
IS A STANDARDIZED ARE TESTING-
SITUATION WHERE PARENTS CAN ASK
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO PROVIDE A
TEST AND THE TEST. IS THEN GIVEN
TO THE CHILD CORRECT AND SO
THAT'S LEFT TO THE DISCRETION OF
THE DISTRICT AND THE PARENTS
TOOK TO TEST THE CHILD IMPROVE
THAT THEIR COMP OPINION C. LEVEL
IS READY TO MOVE ON TO FIRST
GRADE THANK YOU I THINK THE
TIMES HAVE CERTAINLY CHANGED IN
THE OLD DAYS. KINDERGARTEN AND
EVEN PRE SCHOOL WORKING
OBVIOUSLY LUXURIES THAT A LOT OF
KIDS DIDN'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN. BUT I THINK
WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH OUR TEST
RESULTS IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CHALLENGES WITH OUR CHILDREN IS
THAT WE NEED MORE EMPHASIS ON
EARLY EDUCATION MORE OPPORTUNITY
FOR EARLY EDUCATION. THIS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I. KIND
OF ADD IT IS A FINE. AND I THE
ONLY I HAD A CONVERSATION. TO
PRESENTING THE BELL ABOUT.
CANDOR BEING MOSTLY I'VE YOU
KNOW CRAFT SIMPLY TIME AND I
JUST WANNA. MAKE SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE TIMES HAVE
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY SINCE WE
WERE IN SCHOOL. WE WENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE STANDARDS THAT
WERE A LITTLE BIT. MY OPINION
MORE LENIENT TO NOW COMMON CORE.
AND SO IT'S NO LONGER JUST
PLAYTIME ARE KISSING CANDOR ARE
LEARNING HOW TO WRITE. FULL
SENTENCES LEARNING THE NUMBERS.
LEARNING A LOT OF- ACADEMIC
LANGUAGE THAT IS NECESSARY TO
THE BUILDING BLOCKS. TO BEING
READY FOR FIRST GRADE AND FIRST
GRADE. YOU'RE ALREADY RUNNING
WITH ANOTHER SET OF. CRITERIA
FOR EXAMPLE WRITING A FULL
PARAGRAPH SO THEY HAVEN'T.
LEARNED HOW TO WRITE A
SENTENCING CANDOR. THERE ARE
ALREADY AT A DISADVANTAGE WE
NEED THOSE FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS
TO BE SUCCESSFUL. AND I CAN
ATTEST THAT THE GAP WILL GROW
EXPONENTIALLY. AND IT'S HARDER
TO CATCH THEM UP SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR OTHER. THANK YOU
MANAGER- I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR I THINK THAT ALL THE
ISSUES THAT SHE HAS RAISED I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH AND I
THINK A AND I SUPPORT THE BILL
MOVING FORWARD OF THE AUTHOR AND
I HAVE HAD SOME CONVERSATIONS
BUT I JUST WANT TO IDENTIFY SOME
OF THE ISSUES WHICH I WILL I
DON'T EXPECT AN ANSWER RIGHT
NOW. BUT I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE'S A BY
ADDING THE NEW GRADE THERE'S A
BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S AN IMPACT
ON OUR EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
SYSTEM SO YOU KNOW AN IMPACT ON
THE ENROLLMENT AND FUNDING
PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE PROGRAMS
ON IN HOME PROVIDERS AND FAMILY
PROVIDERS- IMPACT ON FAMILIES
WHO RELY ON NON SCHOOL CARE
SETTINGS WITH NONTRADITIONAL
HOURS. OF THESE ARE HALF DAY
PROGRAMS NOT ALL FAMILIES CAN
TRANSPORT CHILDREN IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE WORK DAY- AND THEN THE
IMPACT ON. I'M FEDERAL OF
FUNDING OF FOR EXAMPLE ON HEAD
START PROGRAMS- AND THE SHIP
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
TO SERVING A LARGER. POPULATION
OF ZERO THREE THREE YEAR OLDS-
MY DISTRICT WE HAVE SIX HEAD
START GRANTEES. ARE SERVING OVER
FOUR THOUSAND ARE CHILDREN SO
THESE ARE JUST ISSUES THAT- I
WILL PASS ON TO THE TO THE
AUTHOR. ON I THINK THEY'RE
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT. OF THE INTENDED
CONSEQUENCES BUT THEY ARE
IMPORTANT CONSEQUENCES THAT WE
HAVE TO WATCH OUT FOR THANK YOU
. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
BILL. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THANK NINE CENTER RUBIO
YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU AND
I APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
COMMENTS- BUT I JUST WANNA
FINALLY- AT THAT OUR STUDENTS
MOSTLY ALREADY ATTEND
KINDERGARTEN IT'S ALREADY AGREED
THE ATTEND HOWEVER I'M TRYING TO
JUST CAPTURE THAT SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF KIDS WHO. ARE AS
PARENTS DON'T KNOW IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL DOESN'T
MANDATED SO WE JUST WANT TO
CAPTURE THAT SMALL PERCENTAGE- I
DID WORK VERY DILIGENTLY AS I
MENTIONED FOR THREE YEARS WITH
ALL THE GROUPS THAT WERE JUST
STATED AND I WILL CONTINUE TO BE
OPENED FOR CONVERSATIONS THE
GOAL IS TO ENHANCE EDUCATION.
NOT TO HARM OUR CHILDREN WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL THANK
YOU. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI I. ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER FINE FOR
JUST AYE BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
AYE PROTESTING AYE DODD DURACELL
. I EGGMAN. GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
FIVE GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI
WESTERN. I HER TADO I JONES NO
KAMLAGER. I LAYERED AYE LEYVA
AYE LIMÓN FIVE MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ NO MEN I NEWMAN FIVE
NIELSEN I A CHIRLA BOTH NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER I STERN AYE NUMBER
HI QUITE HOUSEKI. WIENER AYE
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DODD EGGMAN I GROWTH NO
WHITE HOUSE SKI I. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CENTER
NIELSEN. SENATOR NELSON I DON'T
KNOW NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW. FIVE
THIRTY TWO KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO I DON'T FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SENATOR MAN IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. IF YOU
COULD HOLD ON A SECOND. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE BILL
TO EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR MEN AND
AFTER LEADING TO ELECTIONS
CENTERMAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SORRY FOR JUMPING THE
GUN HAS BEEN A FEW WEEKS- I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB TWO EIGHTY
SIX WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE
LECTIONS FOR THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION BE
CONSOLIDATED WITH STATEWIDE
GENERAL ELECTION IN NOVEMBER
INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT PRACTICE
WHICH IS TO HOLD IT DURING THEPRIMARY ELECTION. THIS BILL IS
BASED ON A VERY SIMPLE
PROPOSITION THAT COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION SERVE CRITICAL
FUNCTIONS IN OUR STATE AND
THEREFORE IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE MAKE EVERY EFFORT TO GET MORE
VOTERS INVOLVED IN GAUGED
INFORMED ABOUT THESE CRITICAL
LOCAL GOVERNING BOARDS I'VE
TALKED TO TOO MANY CONSTITUENTS
IN MY DISTRICT HAVE BEEN
CONFUSED BY THE PRACTICE- THAT
WE HAVE NOW WITH ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD EDUCATION IS ELECTED I
SIMPLY ONE AND DONE IN THE
PRIMARY WE'RE ONE OF ONLY FIVE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE THAT DOES
THAT. AND OBVIOUSLY THAT'S A FAR
LOWER TURN OUT IN TWENTY TWENTY
THE PRIMARY HAD ROUGHLY HALF THE
VOTERS AT THE GENERAL ELECTION I
AND I AGAIN MANY VOTERS TO COME
UP TO ME AND SAID THAT THEY FEEL
FRUSTRATED THAT THEY DON'T GET
TO VOTE FOR THEIR BOARD OF
EDUCATION TRUSTEES OUT OF THE
FORTY TWO COUNTIES THAT HAVE
CANDIDATE ELECTIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOR BOARD EDUCATION. ALL
BUT FIVE OF THEM FORTY TWO HAD
THEM IN THE GENERAL ELECTION I
NEED TURNOUT DIFFERENTIALS THAT
RESULTS ARE PARTICULARLY
PRONOUNCED AMONG RACIAL AND
ETHNIC MINORITIES YOUNG PEOPLE
AND LOW PROPENSITY VOTERS BRED
BRINGING THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD
OF EDUCATION IN ALIGNMENT WITH
THE REST OF THE STATE SB TWO
EIGHTY SIX WOULD INCREASE VOTER
PARTICIPATION REDUCE VOTER
CONFUSION I THINK AB POSITIVE
EXTERNALITIES BY CREATING
UNIFORMITY AROUND THE TIMING
ALEXION'S. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. SENATOR NEWMAN. I
THANK YOU PRESIDENT THAT IRA IN
SUPPORT OF TWO EIGHTY SIX- AS
THE SENATOR FROM ORANGE COUNTY
HAS NOTED THE COUNTY BOARD OF
ELECTIONS WITH A FEW OFFICES IN
ORANGE COUNTY. WHICH ELECTIONS
ARE WHOLLY DECIDED ON THE DATE
OF A STATEWIDE PRIMARY- IN
ORANGE COUNTY ACROSS THE STATE
MOST IMPORTANT LIKE TO OFFICES
ARE SELECTED IN TWO STAGES WITH
THE INITIAL VOTE HELD IN THE
PRIMARY ELECTION. AND A RUN OFF
VOTE TO ACHIEVE A MAJORITY
RESULT IN THE GENERAL. COURT OF
THE ARCHAIC ORANGE COUNTY
REGISTER OF VOTERS BETWEEN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TWENTY TWENTY AN
AVERAGE OF 83% MORE ORANGE
COUNTY VOTERS CAST BALLOTS
STATEWIDE GENERAL ELECTIONS THAN
IT STATEWIDE PRIMARY ELECTIONS
BECAUSE OF HOW THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATIONALIST IS HELD
ON THE PRIMARY DATE THERE ARE
POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS OF VOTERS
WHO DO NOT CAST A BALLOT. IN A
WINNING CANDIDATE CAN PREVAIL
WITH WITH NOT ONLY A VERY SMALL
AGGREGATE VOTE TOTAL- BUT ALSO A
TOTAL THAT FILES BEFORE FAR
SHORT OF A MAJORITY. OF THE
DIFFERENCE IN TURNOUT IS PICKING
THOSE WHO AMONG RACIAL AND
ETHNIC MINORITIES IMMIGRANTS AND
YOUNG PEOPLE- AND IT'S WORTH
NOTING THAT THESE ARE EXACTLY
THE PEOPLE MOST AFFECTED BY THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT IS ELECTIONS
ARE INTENDED TO DO MORE ORANGE
COUNTY RESIDENTS WILL HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD. AND ULTIMATELY
THEIR INTERESTS REPRESENTED AS
THE VOTE FOR IMPORTANT ELECTIVE
OFFICE THAT IS INCREASINGLY
DRAWN PUBLIC SCRUTINY IN RECENT
YEARS THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
SHOULD TAKE EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
TO INCREASE SPECIFIC
PARTICIPATION IN ELECTIONS LARGE
OR SMALL I COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM PROVIDE FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THIS
MORNING. SENATOR A TROUBLE.
THANK YOU MADAM I DO HAVE A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO- MY
COLLEAGUE AT THROUGH THE
PRESIDENT I MAY CENTER MEN YES
OKAY QUESTION. THANK YOU I'M
THINKING MAYBE WE HAD A
QUESTION- AND I'M NOT SURE IF
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT BUT- AS AS I STATED IN THE
COMMITTEE IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT IT'S ALREADY IN STATUTE.
I'M HAVING THE ABILITY FOR THE
LOCAL COUNTY. BOARD OF EDUCATION
TO CHOOSE TO CHANGE THE DATE OF
THE ELECTION. AND BEING THAT
IT'S ALREADY SUCH A HAD ASKED
WHETHER OR NOT IT HAD ALREADY
BRING BY THAT BROUGHT UP TO. THE
TO THE BOARD BY THEIR OWN
CONSTITUENTS TO SEE WHETHER OR
NOT IT WAS A CONCERN AND THEY
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT- IT
COULD BE CHANGED SO I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU HAD FOLLOWED UP
ON THAT AND WHETHER OR NOT IT
HAD BEEN BROUGHT UP TO THE BOARD
FOR LOCAL DECISION MAKING. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- I
APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR AND I'D
SAY WE DID FOLLOW UP WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO DRILL DOWN AND A 100%
CERTAIN ANSWER WHICH IS WHY WE
DIDN'T RESPOND- YET BUT- WHAT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE'S
NOT BEEN A FORMAL PROPOSAL MADE
TO THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. BUT THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF CONSTITUENTS AND
OTHERS WHO HAVE BROUGHT THIS UP
TO MEMBERS INDIVIDUALLY ABOUT
THE DIP IDEA OF MOVING THIS
ELECTION TO. NOVEMBER SO IT IS
SHORT ANSWERS I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S BEEN A FORMAL PROPOSAL
MADE BUT THERE HAVE BEEN
INFORMAL ENQUIRIES. I DO HAVE A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION MADAM
PRESIDENT YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU. SO IN OTHER WORDS WE HAVING
GIVEN. IN STATUTE IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT YES AND
THAT BEING SAID I THINK THE
GENERAL TENOR IN BELIEF BY MANY
CONSTITUENTS IS THAT THIS.
PARTICULAR BOARD OF EDUCATION I
IS VERY PARTISAN AND IS UNLIKELY
TO MOVE THAT I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY REFLECTED IN SOME OF
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY MADE ABOUT THIS BILL.
NONE OF WHICH HAVE SUBSTANCE
LIAM SUBSTANTIVELY ADDRESS THAT
THE IDEA OF MOVING ELECTION FROM
THE PRIMARY TO THE NOVEMBER
GENERAL ELECTION- BUT WHICH HAVE
REALLY ENGAGE IN A LOT OF
VITRIOLIC STATEMENTS IN.
INCLUDING SOME ONES THAT ARE
PERSONAL OFFENSIVE IN AND SO I
THINK THE SENSE IS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR MAKE UP OF THIS
BOARD. IS NOT LIKELY TO MOVE IT.
OKAY SO MY COMMENTS COMING FROM
A LOCAL PERSPECTIVE AS FAR AS
GOVERNMENT GOES I ALWAYS FEEL
THAT THE CONSTITUENTS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO POWER TO CHANGE THE
LOCAL BOARD IF THEY'RE NOT HAPPY
WITH THE DECISIONS ARE BEING
MADE IN THAT DIRECTION SO- I AM
VERY HESITANT TO BRING THIS TO
THE STATE LEVEL TO INTRUDE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHEN THEY
HAVEN'T HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS IT LOCALLY SO I
RESPECTFULLY WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
SENATOR BRIDGES. I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES- JUST SAID I THINK
SOME OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
POINTS. IT WOULD BE A MISTAKE TO
THINK THAT THIS IS A DISTRICT
FILL. THISIS NOT A DISTRICT
BILL. THIS IS A BILL THAT IS
SEEKING TO TAKE THE STRONG ARM
OF THE STATE. N. R. ORCHESTRATE-
IN OUTCOME AT A LOCAL LEVEL. I
KNOW A LOT OF YOU ARE IN THIS
ROOM BELIEVE IN LOCAL AUTHORITY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE WHERE LOCAL AUTHORITIES
SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES. WHETHER A
PRIMARY SHOULD BE IN A- IN A- IN
JUNE OR THERE MIGHT BE A GENERAL
IN WHATEVER FORMAT THAT THEY SEE
FIT. AND I THINK HEARING THE
MOTIVATION BEHIND THIS- WAS EVEN
MORE DISTURBING THAT THE
PARTISAN NATURE OF THE BOARD
WOULD DISALLOW THIS SO WHAT HAS
TO BE DONE AT THE STATE. IS THAT
THE NATURE OF OUR FORM OF
GOVERNMENT. THAT THE
DETERMINATIVE BODY IF THEY
DECIDE TO DO SOMETHING OR NOT DO
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE DECIDED
THERE IN THAT ENDS IN THAT IS
THE ISSUE. THIS IS TERRIBLY
DANGEROUS FOR US TO LOOK UPON
THIS AS A DISTRICT BILL BECAUSE
IT IS USING THE STATE RESURFACED
THE STRONG ARM OF THE STATE TO
COME IN AND TELL THEM THAT IF
YOU DON'T DO WHAT WE WANT YOU TO
DO THAT WE WILL CHANGE THE
RULES. IN MORE INTELLECTUALLY ON
BROOCH WHAT FOR TO BE A COMPLETE
STATEWIDE PROCESS WHERE
PRIMARIES IN GENERAL ARE
DETERMINED ACROSS THE STATE BUT
I HEARD THERE WAS A LEASE FIVE
JURISDICTIONS THEY DON'T DO IT
IN THAT FASHION. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUE AND I
HAVE THE HIGHEST RESPECT FOR HIM
. TO REVISIT THIS I THINK IT BE
BETTER SUITED NOT IN ADDITION
BILL FORMAT BUT AS A MATTER OF
STATE POLICY AND THEN WE CAN
DEBATE ON THE MERITS IN THAT
FASHION. SENATOR UMBERG. I JOIN
MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES FROM
FULLERTON AND IRVINE IN
SUPPORTING S. B. AT TWO EIGHTY
SIX I TAKE THE POINT- THAT OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO REYES BUT
IT IS A STATE WIDE INTEREST I
THINK TO MAKE SURE THAT
ELECTIONS HAVE THE GREATEST
PARTICIPATION AS IS POSSIBLE
THIS IS A UNIQUE COLLECTION IT'S
A PLURALITY VOTE AND IT SHOULD
BE DONE- WITH THE LARGEST
CONSTITUENCY THE LARGEST
ELECTORATE AS IS POSSIBLE NUMBER
I URGE. SENATOR NEWMAN. AT THANK
YOU MEASURE DUBBED AS SOMEBODY
WHO SPOKE IN SUPPORT OF THAT I'D
LIKE TO RESPOND TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FRESNO JUST TO BE VERY
CLEAR- MY INTEREST AND I THINK I
CAN SPEAK FOR OTHERS- AND FOR
THOSE WHO VOTED COMMITTEE IT
THERE THERE'S NO PARTISAN ANIMUS
TO THIS VOTE- THE QUESTION HERE
IS WHETHER OR NOT THE ELECTION
FOR A VERY IMPORTANT OFFICE FOR
COUNTY WIDE EDUCATION OFFICE.
SHOULD THE RESULT SHOULD BE AS
REPRESENTATIVE AS POSSIBLE- HOW
WHATEVER FORM THAT TAKES BY WAY
OF PARTISAN RESULT IS IMMATERIAL
TO ME IT'S THIS IS A MATTER OF
EQUITY NOW THIS IS A MATTER
PARTICIPATION- AND ENSURING THAT
THE VOICES OF THOSE MOST
AFFECTED ARE HEARD- AND I KNOW
THAT MY COLLEAGUE LEVINE WILL
POINT THIS OUT- HIS INITIAL
INTENT WAS WAS ACTUALLY TO MAKE
THIS A STATEWIDE BILL- AND THERE
WERE MANY WHO SUPPORTED THAT THE
DECISION WAS MADE AS IT MOVED
THROUGH COMMITTEE. THAT TO LIMIT
THIS TO ORANGE COUNTY FOR NOW-
THAT'S THE BASIS OF OUR VOTE
TODAY- AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT IT
IS NECESSARY IMPORTANT PRECISELY
BECAUSE THE MEMBERSHIP OF THIS
BOARD IS THE LEAST INCLINED TO
CONSIDER THE POSSIBILITY OF
CHANGING LOCAL- AND THAT
UNFORTUNATELY IS WHY NOW WE FEEL
THE NEED TO DO THAT HERE. IN
SACRAMENTO TODAY THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DOES OR TO BE.
SENATOR- CHIU. SO I'M RESPONSE
TO MY COLLEAGUES I DON'T THINK
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER OR NOT
WE BELIEVE THAT- IT'S TO THE
INTENT TO HAVE THE GREATEST
TURNOUT FOR VOTERS I THINK THE
QUESTION HERE REMAINS AT LEAST
FOR ME PERSONALLY. THE FACT THAT
IT'S ALREADY IN STATUTE THAT
THESE ELECTIONS CAN BE CHANGED-
AND IT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED
LOCALLY WHICH HAS NOT BEING
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ADDRESSED COOLEY TO CHANGE THAT.
WHETHER OR NOT THE MAKE UP
HEATERS TO THAT TO THAT CHANGE I
THINK SHOULD BE DECIDED BY THE
LOCAL RESIDENTS AND LOCAL
CONSTITUENTS WHO VOTE IN THOSE
BOARD MEMBERS SO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING HERE IS THAT. IF WE
SUPERSEDE THE LOCAL CONSTITUENTS
WERE SAYING THAT THE STATE IS
TELLING THE LOCAL PEOPLE. HOW
THEY SHOULD GO WHAT THEY SHOULD
DO AND I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT IS
ACTUALLY A FAIR- AND QUITE
FRANKLY- SERVICE PLEASE. RIGHT
WORD FAT. WE ARE OVERSTEPPING ON
LOCAL VOTING CONSTITUENTS AND
WHAT THEY WANT IF THEY DON'T DO
NOT AGREE WITH OUR LOCAL BOARD
LOCAL CONSTITUENTS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY HAVE THE POWER TO
CHANGE THAT PORT AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEING HERE IS BECAUSE WE DON'T
AGREE WITH THAT BOARD THAT THE
STATE HAS THE POWER TO COME OVER
AND SAY OKAY THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO. SO I THINK FOR ME
THE BIGGEST CONCERN IS THAT WE
SHOULD ALLOW THE LOCAL
CONSTITUENTS TO CHOOSE THE BOARD
THAT THEY WISH AND HAVE THE
BOARD THEN DIRECT AT WENDY'S
ELECTIONS ARE ADDRESSED THE
ISSUE THERE LOCALLY I THINK
THAT'S THE BIGGEST CONCERN FOR
ME. YOUR ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER MENU MAKE INCLUDE YES IF
I COULD RESPOND TO A FEW MIKE-
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR SO
I THINK MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES
FROM ORANGE COUNTY FOR
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I IN
RESPONSE MY COLLEAGUES FROM
YUCAIPA IN FRESNO I WOULD I
WOULD JUST SAY THIS THE ORIGINS
OF THIS BILL WERE BASED ON THE
IDEA THAT WE SHOULD HAVE MAXIMUM
TURNOUT. AND IN RESPONSE THE
IDEA THAT THIS IS A LOCAL MATTER
I'LL JUST POINT OUT THAT THE
ABILITY TO CHANGE THIS ELECTION
DATE HAS EXISTED FOR SOMETHING
LIKE TWENTY TO THIRTY YEARS AND
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED AND THIS
BILL IS NOT PARTISAN IN NATURE
AS AS MY COLLEAGUE IMPORTANT
POINTED OUT I TRY TO APPLY THIS
INITIALLY TO ALL COUNTY WIDE
ELECTIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
UNFORTUNATE THAT BILL DID NOT
HAVE ENOUGH SUPPORT TO GET OUT
OF COMMITTEES- SO I NEVER TO
ORANGE COUNTY AND TO THE ONE
BODY THAT HAS ELECTIONS WE
DECIDED IN A PRIMER THERE'S NO
OTHER SIGNIFICANT BODY OUT THERE
THAT DOES THIS OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ARE SHERIFFS ALL HAVE
A TOP TWO THAT ADVANCES OUT IF
SOME UNLESS SOMEONE GETS 50% THE
PRIMARY. ARE STATE LEGISLATIVE
OFFICES IN OUR FEDERAL OFFICES
COURSE HEAVY TOP TO THE DANCE IS
THE GENERAL ELECTION INTO YOUR
THE TWO MIGHT THE POINT MADE BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM YUCAIPA ABOUT
ALLOWING LOCAL CONSTITUENTS TO
DECIDE THIS LOCALLY THAT'S
PRECISELY THE POINT OF THIS BILL
I'VE TALKED TO TOO MANY PEOPLE
WHO DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT THEY
GET TO VOTE FOR BOARD OF
EDUCATION SIMPLY DON'T
PARTICIPATE GENERALLY IN
PRIMARIES. MOST PEOPLE OUT THERE
BELIEVE IT WITH SAWDUST
EDUCATION THE PRIMARIES ARE
MEANT TO DECIDE YOUR CHOICES FOR
THE GENERAL ELECTION AND SO THEY
JUST GENERAL ELECTION TO DECIDE
THE BOOK BETWEEN THOSE TOP TWO
THEY NEVER GET THAT CHANCE AND
NEVER GET THE CHANCE TO CHANGE
THE MAKE UP OF THAT BOARD AND SO
THIS BILL IS BASED ON THE IDEA
THAT WE SHOULD GET RID OF THAT
CONFUSION. WE SHOULD MAXIMIZE
TURN OUT. IN POWER AT THE TYPES
OF VOTERS IN MY COLLEAGUES IN
FULLERTON I BOTH MENTIONED YEAH
PEOPLE IN THE- PEOPLE LET.
BURGER GO TO SCHOOL OR FOR SOME
OTHER REASON AND EMPOWER THEM
TO. THEIR ALSO THAT WE GET A
CALL. WE BACK. CLARITY AND WE
GET. TURNOUT FOR BY THIS. VERY
IN. AND SAW WITH ALL THAT I SAY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BAKER FIVE FORTUS NO
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
PROTESTING AYE DODD DURACELL I
EGGMAN. FIVE GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO HI FURTADO. I JONES NO
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA HI
THE MON I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
NO MEN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN.
HI. I A SHOW VOTE NO TAM I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE NUMBER I
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE
WILK NO. NIELSEN I TO KNOW. FIVE
THIRTY NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY NINE.
SENATOR WIENER HE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO GREENHOUSE GASES
CENTER WIENER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PRESIDENT BY COLLEAGUES SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTY THE CLIMATE
CORPORATE ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
WILL REQUIRE ALL US BASED
COMPANIES WITH OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL REVENUE AND
WHO DO BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA-
TO REPORT THEIR FULL CARBON
FOOTPRINT- TO THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND SECRETARY OF
STATE. AFTER THIS DISCLOSURE-
CAR WILL BE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
A REPORT ON THESE ENTITIES-
WORKING WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE- THIS REPORT WILL INCLUDE
A ROAD MAP- ADVISORY FOR THESE
CORPORATIONS ABOUT HOW TO LOWER
THEIR CARBON EMISSIONS. IN
ORDER- TO KEEP US ON TRACK TO
PUT US ON TRACK. TO MEET THE
MAXIMUM WARMING LEVELS THAT WE
KNOW ARE WE NEED TO COMPLY WITH
A TO BELOW ONE POINT FIVE
DEGREES CELSIUS- THIS REPORT
WILL ALSO INCLUDE REASONABLE
ESTIMATES- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE CALLS ARE PROPERLY
IMPLEMENTED. SB TWO SIXTY OF THE
NECESSARY IN BOLD STEP FORWARD
TO ENSURE THAT WE NOT ONLY HIT
OUR CURRENT CLIMATE GOALS BUT
HOW THE NECESSARY DATA AND
INFORMATION- TO REALLY MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE TACKLING THIS
EXISTENTIAL CRISIS. FOR OUR
PLANET YOU CAN'T. REGULATE WHAT
YOU DON'T KNOW CONSUMERS CAN
MAKE DECISIONS. WITHIN ON
INFORMATION INVESTORS CAN MAKE
DECISIONS AND WE NEED THE STATE
OF. EARLY CALLING THERE ARE
COURT. THAT ARE COMPILING THIS
DATA SOME OF THEM DISCLOSE THAT
DATA. SOME OF THEM DON'T. SOME
OF THEM ONLY DISCLOSE PARTIAL
DATA AND EXCLUDE SIGNIFICANT
ELEMENTS OF THEIR OPERATIONS
THERE IS NO CONSISTENCY HERE. I
AM THIS BILL WILL BRING
CONSISTENCY AND USE WELL
ESTABLISHED METHODOLOGIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL LARGE
CORPORATIONS DOING BUSINESS IN
OUR STATE. ARE DISCLOSING IN A
STANDARDIZED WAY AND THE
CONSUMERS AND GOVERNMENT AND
INVESTORS AND THE PUBLIC IN
GENERAL HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION RIGHT NOW COMPANIES
ARE EASILY ABLE TO GREEN WASH%
WHAT IS I MEAN. THEY PUT OUT
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW GREEN THEY
ARE. BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING THEY'RE NOT
GREEN WE JUST LEARNED THIS
RECENTLY WITH CELL. A MAJOR
CORPORATION WHICH HAS A CARBON
CAPTURE PROGRAM IN CANADA THAT
IS LITERALLY EMITTING MORE
CARBON THAN IT'S CAPTURING. WE-SHOULD HAVE THAT DATA FOR ALL
CORPORATIONS SO THAT WE HAVE-
ACCOUNTABILITY. I'M COLLEAGUES I
KNOW THIS BILL HAS THERE'S A LOT
OF OPINIONS ABOUT THIS BUT WE
HAVE A HUGE COALITION
SUPPORTING. THE BILL AND I KNOW
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN CONCERNS
RAISED BY ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING WORKERS
REPRESENTING BUSINESSES. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING FOR THE LAST YEAR
I'M ON THIS BILLWITH THOSE WHO
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS AND WE'VE
MADE SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
BASED ON THOSE CONVERSATIONS. WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND I WILL
BE CONTINUING TO MEET WITH AND
WORK WITH. ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS ON IF THIS
GETS OUT OF THE SENATE WILL DO
THAT WORK IN THE ASSEMBLY WILL
CONTINUE THAT WORK- AND
COLLEAGUES- I ALSO KNOW THERE'S
CONTINUING WORK. ABOUT THE EXACT
THE MINISTRATION IN TERMS OF
WHAT AGENCY WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR WHAT WE MADE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS SOME
CONCERNS. THAT WILL BE-
CONTINUING WORK- IN THE ASSEMBLY
IF THE BILL GETS TO THE ASSEMBLY
ASA COLLEAGUES THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT CLIMATE ACTION BILL.
HI INFORMATION AND DATA ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SENATOR
PENN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO SIXTY- IS IT A PERFECT
BILL NOW I HAVE SOME ISSUES- AND
I APPRECIATE MY CONVERSATIONS
WITH MY GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE CLIMATE CRISIS IS A CRISIS.
AND EVEN THOSE WERE STRUGGLING
OF COVETED WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
CLOCK IS TICKING ON CLIMATE.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE GOOD
DATA THAT WE HAVE REPORTING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON. NOW
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT-
ONE OF MY MAJOR CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL ORIGINALLY. AND IS
THAT- I WANT TO BE SURE THAT-
SMALL BUSINESSES PARTICULARLY
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
IMMIGRANT BUSINESSES. ARE NOT
REMOVED FROM BEING ABLE TO. HAVE
CONTRACTS TO BE PART OF SUPPLY
CHAIN FOR THESE LARGE
CORPORATIONS WE DON'T WANT TO
DENY- ENTREPRENEURS TYPICALLY
IMMIGRANTS AND- ENTREPRENEURS OF
COLOR FROM BE ABLE TO ENGAGE
BECAUSE OF ONEROUS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OR OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
AUTHOR- TOOK AMENDMENTS TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR
CONCERN. I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S INTERESTING ENOUGH
CONCERNS ABOUT THE ACCURACY OF
THE DATA I HOPE THAT'S NOT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE OPPOSITION TO
THE FACT THAT I ACTUALLY WANT TO
ALLOW THESE BUSINESSES TO BE
ABLE TO DO ESTIMATES SO THAT WE
DON'T OVERBURDEN REPORTING. SO I
KNOW THEY'RE SOMETIMES THERE'S
CONFLICTING THINGS BUT- IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE GIVE IN MY
OPINION THAT- WE GIVE THE AUTHOR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. SO THAT WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION WE NEED. MAKE
POLICY. TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS I WILL ALSO POINT OUT AS
WELL. I KNOW THIS ONE FAMILY
DEALS WITH BILLION DOLLAR PLUS
CORPORATIONS. THAT I'VE ACTUALLY
CALLED ON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS CERTAINLY A LARGE
EMPLOYER THE LARGEST IMPACT IN
MY DISTRICT. TO ALSO PERHAPS DO
THE SAME IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
ESTABLISH CLIMATE YOU KNOW-
FOOT. PLANET FOOTPRINT FOR A
GREENHOUSE THE PRINGLES. AND TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO REDUCE
THAT WORKING. WITH THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND OTHERS IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT THE- COMPANY OR THE
ORGANIZATION ITSELF IT'S ABOUT
HOW THEY DO BUSINESS. WITH OTHER
ENTITIES AS WELL AND HOW IT AND
IN TERMS OF PRIORITIZING THIS.
SO I THINK THIS IS A WERE THE
BILL TO MOVE FORWARD- IT'S AN
IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE I THINK THE AUTHORS ARE
READY- DRESSED MANY ISSUES HERE
IN THE SENATE AND DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY CONTINUE TO DO THAT
IN THE ASSEMBLY. I KNOW THAT
AND- SO I THINK. WE NEED TO HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT. INFORMATION AT THIS BILL
CALLS FOR. AND I'M SET UP
FINANCED THAT MY GOOD FROM FROM
ST STE MY GOOD FRIENDS IN SAN
FRANCISCO. WILL CONTINUE THAT
WORK AND COME BACK TO US WHEN HE
COMES BACK IN CONCURRENCE. WITH
AN EXCELLENT BUILD ALL HELP US
ADDRESS THE CRISIS. THEREFORE I
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON. SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU MADAM RAISES A
PROUD JOIN AUTHOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND I WOULD SUBMIT
COLLEAGUES THAT THIS IS BOTH-
PRO BUSINESS AND PRO LABOR PIECE
OF LEGISLATION- WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT CORPORATIONS A
BILLION DOLLARS OR GREATER AS
THIS BILL COVERS. AND THOSE
CORPORATIONS ARE MAKING
ASSERTIONS ABOUT BEING NET ZERO
OR CARBON NEUTRAL AS IS BECOMING
A GROWING TREND. YOU SEE AMAZON
OUT THERE DOING IT. YOU SEEN
EXXON MOBIL ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK-
NET ZERO COMMITMENT. BUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN THEY SAY IT- THAT
THE MATH BEHIND IT IS SOMETHING
THAT'STRANSPARENT AND ACCURATE
FOR PEOPLE TO HANG OUR HATS ON-
I THINK DOING HONEST MATH. WILL
ACTUALLY HELP CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES THAT WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA LABOR ORGANIZATIONS.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES OUT THERE OR THE
FOLKS STRUGGLING ALONG THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. WITH THESE GLOBAL
CORPORATIONS THE INCENTIVE WILL
BE TO BRING BUSINESS BACK TO
CALIFORNIA TO DO THAT WORK. IF
YOU WANT TO LOWER YOUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT THE BEST THING YOU CAN
DO IS RELY ON LOCAL LABOR. AND
LOCAL SUPPLIES WHETHER YOU'RE
MAKING A HAMBURGER OR SHIPPING
SOMEONE A NEW PAIR OF JEANS AND
I THINK THE INCENTIVE TO HAVE
THAT MAPPED OUT THERE WITHOUT
ANY REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
OBLIGATION LET'S BE CLEAR THIS
IS NOT A NEW REGULATORY REGIME
THIS IS NOT A NEW ENFORCEMENT
PROTOCOL THIS IS JUST ABOUT
STANDARDIZING THE MATH. AND SO
WHEN EXXON MOBIL GOES OUT AND
SAYS THEIR NET ZERO BUT THEY SAY
OH BUT WE DIDN'T INCLUDE ANY OF
THE EMISSIONS FROM COMBUSTION
ALL OF OUR GASOLINE ALL OVER THE
WORLD. BUT WE'RE NOT ZERO. IS
THAT REALLY FAIR. SO I WOULD I
WOULD SUBMIT- THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA THAT
THIS IS NOT SUPERFLUOUS DATA AND
THAT WHEN PEOPLE SAY SOMETHING-
THEY HAVE TO MEET IT. AND
ESPECIALLY CORPORATIONS IF WE'RE
GOING TO TREAT THEM LIKE OTHER
PEOPLE THEY HAVE TO MEAN IT TOO.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
CENTER GROVE. AT CENTER GROVE
NOPE CENTER JOHNSON. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST WANTED TO
COMMENT BRIEFLY YOU KNOW THAT ON
THIS FOR AND ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF
ANECDOTAL AND SCIENTIFIC DEBATE
ON. GLOBAL WARMING GLOBAL
CLIMATE CHANGE SEA LEVEL RISE.
BUSINESS REGULATION AND THE
IMPACTS OF A POLICIES ON
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
ONE THING THAT'S NOT OUR TO
THINGS THAT AREN'T ADDING
ANECDOTAL THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
NEWS RECENTLY AND THAT WERE ALL
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW IS FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'VE LOST A
CONGRESSIONAL SEAT THAT'S NOT
ANECDOTAL. WHAT CAUSES A STATE
TO LOSE A CONGRESSIONAL SEAT IS
WHEN PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT STATE.
AND WE BET BEGAN SEEING THIS IN
THE EIGHTIES WITH WHAT NOW IS
CALLED THE RUST BELT STATES.
WHEN THEY BEGIN LOSING
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS THEY STILL
HAVE NOT RECOVERED. FROM THOSE
LOSSES IN SOME OF THOSE STATES
EVEN CONTINUE TO LOSE
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS. THIS YEAR.
N. AS STATES LOSE CONGRESSIONAL
SEATS THEY LOSE POLITICAL
INFLUENCE AND POWER IN
WASHINGTON DC. AND I WOULD HATE
TO SEE OUR STATE MOVE
CONTINUOUSLY IN THAT DIRECTION.
THE SECOND THING IS NOT
ANECDOTAL I WAS THE HEADLINE
LAST WEEK IS THE MOVING COMPANY
YOU HALL ACTUALLY RAN OUT OF
VEHICLES. PEOPLE MOVING OUT OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT IS AN
UNBELIEVABLE STATISTIC AND
STATEMENT OF FACT THAT ONE OF
THE LARGEST MOVING COMPANIES IN
THE COUNTRY ACTUALLY RAN OUT OF
VEHICLES FOR PEOPLE LEAVING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HELLO WE
CAN HAVE A DEBATE ON GLOBAL
WARMING AND ITS IMPACTS ON
BUSINESSES AND I THINK WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL OF THOSE ROBUST DEBATE.
BUT WHEN WE GET DOWN THE BOTTOM
LINE OF POLICIES SUCH AS THIS
ONE. WE HAVE TO ANALYZE. IS THIS
COMPOUNDING THE PROBLEM. OF
COMPANIES TRYING TO DO BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE TALK ABOUT
BILLION DOLLAR COMPANIES YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE IMAGES WERE
TRYING TO PRO TRAIN THAT IS
BILLIONAIRES AND MILLIONAIRES.
BUT ONE OF THE IMPACTS THAT WE
FORGET IT IS IT'S ACTUALLY
MIDDLE CLASS AND MORTGAGE
PLAYING PAYING CALIFORNIANS THAT
WORK FOR THESE BILLION DOLLAR
COMPANIES. AND JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE BILLION DOLLAR COMPANY
DOESN'T MEAN THEY MAKE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN PROFIT. MEANS THEY
HAVE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
REVENUE AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN EXPENSES OF LABOR. AND PEOPLE
THAT ARE LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
WORKING IN CALIFORNIA WANT TO
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA AND WANT TO
STAY IN CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK
AS WE PROVIDE PROGRESS OVER THIS
COMING YEAR IT WOULD BE REALLY
WISE OF US. TO LOOK AT POLICIES
SUCH AS THIS. AND I ACKNOWLEDGE
THE AUTHOR AS BEING COMMITTED
TO. SOLVING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROBLEMS OF CALIFORNIA. BUT THIS
PARTICULAR POLICY I THINK DOES
NOT DO THAT BUT DOES COMPOUND
THE PROBLEM y
AT CALIFORNIA AS A PLACE TO DO
BUSINESS. COMPANIES THERE IN
CALIFORNIA WANTING TO STAY IN
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ANALYZING POLICIES LIKE THIS AND
HAVING TO MAKE AN ECONOMIC
DECISION ON WHETHER TO STAY OR
NOT. I WOULD SUGGEST MEMBERS
TODAY THAT WE WOULD PASS ON THIS
BILL AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
URGE A NO VOTE. SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE AS
ONE WHO SOMETIMES BEEN CAUGHT IN
BETWEEN- WITH SINCE THE
RESERVATIONS AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTEE TALK TO ABOUT THE
CUT THE CUT ADDITIONAL COST
INCURRED BY BUSINESS BUT ALSO
THE PERSPECTIVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF LEGISLATION SUCH
AS THIS. I WILL BE VOTING FOR
THIS MEASURE TODAY I'D LIKE TO
ALIGN MYSELF WITH MY COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO I CLEARLY YOU KNOW
THE BROADER SUBJECT IS VERY
IMPORTANT THE ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION MECHANICS BAR ARE
NO SMALL THING- AND I AM GLAD TO
ACCEPT MY COLLEAGUES OFFER- TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL
PARTIES. TO AMONG OTHER THINGS
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE CLEAR
OBJECTIVES STANDARDS FOR
MEASURING CARBON- AND SO THAT
EVERYBODY PARTICIPATING THIS
PROCESS- IS RECEIVING THE SAME
GUIDANCE- AND COMING UP WITH
DATA THAT IS- EQUIPMENT ON AN
APPLES TO APPLES BASIS- AND ALSO
IN SO DOING INSURING THAT THAT
THE SMALLER PARTICIPANTS. IN
SUPPLY CHAINS AREN'T
UNINTENTIONALLY EXCLUDED BECAUSE
OF THEIR INABILITY TO IT HERE-
TO ANY DISNEY REQUIREMENTS SO
WITH THAT. AND WE SHOULD THE
AVERAGE AND WOULD WOULD COMMEND
MY CALL. TO CONTINUE TO WITH
ALSO TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
RESOLVE THAT WE CAN ALL LIVE
WITH THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON MY A
COLLEAGUE FROM SANDY'S COMMENTS
AND HAVE A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. WILL YOU ACCEPT IT A
QUESTION. HE WILL THANK YOU- I
GUESS THERE IS SOME AMBIGUITY IS
THE BILL IN YOUR INTENT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN GLOBAL
REVENUE OR ONE BILLION DOLLARS
AND- MEANING TOTAL REVENUE BUT
LESS ALL EXPENSES OR IS IT TOTAL
PROFIT SO IS IT TOTAL REVENUE.
OR TOTAL PROFIT. THIRD THROUGH
THE CHAIR- IT'S REVENUE IT IS
TOTAL REVENUE SO I DO WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS FROM SANTEE TO TELL YOU
THAT MOST OF THOSE BILLION
DOLLAR CORPORATIONS DOING PLACE
SMALL EMPLOYERS MEDIAN SIZE
EMPLOYERS THAT PROVIDE TENS OF
THOUSANDS IF NOT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA NOT EVERYBODY STEP
INTO AN AMAZON POSITION- WHETHER
YOU'RE SMALL MINORITY
DISADVANTAGED- BUSINESS OWNER.
YOU CAN STEP INTO THAT POSITION
TO PROVIDE ALL THOSE JOBS FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE EMPLOYED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I THINK
THAT THE COST OF TO THE REST OF
THE GREEN TRANSITION IS ALREADY
DISASTROUS IN UNDENIABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S BEING PAID FOR
IT AT THE VERY LIMITED
DISCRETIONARY INCOME OF EVERY
CALIFORNIANS. INCLUDING OUR MOST
FOR THE PAY THE SAME GAS PRICES
WE DO. AN ON A MINIMAL
DISCRETIONARY INCOME. HIGHER
COST OF LIVING HIGHER COST OF
INFLATION HER GUTS TO GOODS OF
TRANSPORTATION SO THAT ITEMS AND
COMMODITIES CAN BE BROUGHT TO
THE MARKET- THE LATEST
GOVERNMENT CENSUS TELLS US THAT
WE HAVE THE SECOND HIGHEST
HOMELESS RATE IN THE NATION.
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE IT WAS
STATED EARLIER ONE PAYCHECK AWAY
FROM LOSING THEIR HOME- THIS
FURTHER ADVANCES THAT. 36% OF
THE HOMELESS OR NEAR THE POVERTY
LEVEL. OR HOME SKEWS ME THIRTY
SPUR 6% OF THE HOMES ARE AT NEAR
OR AT THE POVERTY LEVEL EIGHTEEN
POINT 2% OR BELOW THE POVERTY
LEVEL. THESE FIGURES ARE 45255%
HIGHER EVERY STATE THAT BORDERS
CALIFORNIA. FUEL COSTING
CALIFORNIA ALREADY THE HIGHEST
IN THE NATION BETWEEN 25235%
HIGHER IN BORDERING STATES. I
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING THE SIXTEENTH
SENATE DISTRICT AND THAT SPANS
FROM CURRENT TO TULARE ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO NEEDLES AND NEEDLES
WHEN YOU GO TO NEEDLES YOU JUST
HAVE TO DRIVE A QUARTER MILE UP
ACROSS THE BRIDGE TO ARIZONA YOU
PAY TWO DOLLARS LESS A GALLON
FOR GAS. SO WHETHER YOU ARE
WEALTHY OR YOU ARE POOR YOU
STILL PAY HIGHER GAS PRICES IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF POLICIES
THAT ACCESS TO GREEN TECHNOLOGY.
FUEL COSTS IN CALIFORNIA THE
HIGHEST IN THE NATION
ELECTRICITY COSTS ARE TWO TO
THREE TIMES HIGHER THAN ANY
BORDERING STATE. YOU CREATE
POVERTY INDUSTRY DISCRETIONARY
INCOME WITH THE DETRIMENTAL
POLICIES. THAT ARE PASSED IN
THIS BUILDING. I ONCE HAD A ARE.
HEARD WITH AN INDIVIDUAL AT THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
IS A COUPLE YEARS AGO. AND IT
HAD TO DO WITH REVENUE SOURCES
IT HAD TO DO WITH- BUDGETS. FOR
THESE AGENCIES. AND I TRIED TO
EXPLAIN TO THE THAT INDIVIDUAL
AS WELL AS I'M GOING TO TRY TO
EXPLAIN TO ALL OF YOU TODAY.
THAT IS THE PRIVATE BUSINESS
SECTOR. EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR THAT
WE SPEND UP HERE. COMES FROM
PRIVATE BUSINESS SECTOR. NOW
YOU'LL SAY I PAY TAXES JUST LIKE
THAT INDIVIDUAL AT THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
SAYS WILL I PAY TAXES. YEAH BUT
YOU'RE A REGIONAL REVENUE SOURCE
COMES FROM PRIVATE BUSINESS. SHE
SAID SHE NEVER WORKED FOR
PRIVATE BUSINESS WE FEE PRIVATE
BUSINESS WE MAKE THEM PAY FOR
PERMITS AND WE WILL MAKE THEM
PAY I BELIEVE THIS THE ANALYSIS
SAYS THAT THEY'LL BE FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERATED
FROM THIS BILL. FROM PRIVATE
BUSINESS TO FIND A RESOURCE
BOARD POSITIONS. TO FUND
GOVERNMENT. GOVERNMENT OUR SKIS
ME PRIVATE BUSINESS PAYS
EMPLOYEES THEY PAY TAXES ON
THEIR PROPERTY THEY PAY TAXES ON
THEIR REVENUE THEY PAY TAXES ON
AND PAYING EMPLOYEES THEY PAID
THOSE EMPLOYEES AT THE EMPLOYEE
PAY TAXES AND ALL OF THAT
REVENUE COMES TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. TO CONTINUE TO FILE-
A PASS THAT LEGISLATION THAT
HARMS PRIVATE BUSINESS WHERE WE
HAVE AN EXODUS OF PEOPLE LEAVING
THE STATE. IS JUST IT'S
RIDICULOUS I MEAN I DON'T KNOW
WHERE WE EXPECT TO GET THE
REVENUE THAT YOU WANT TO FOR THE
POLICIES THAT THAT ARE PASSING
OUT OF THIS BUSINESS. TO ADD
ANOTHER COMMENT THAT MY
COLLEAGUES- FROM SANTEE MADE
WHICH IS A VERY GOOD ARGUMENT-
THESE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THAT ALSO
OPERATE GLOBALLY. IS IT A
VIOLATION OF THE COMMERCE ACT
AND I GUESS QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR IS IT A VIOLATION OF THE
COMMISSARY QUESTION THE AUTHOR.
WE ACCEPT ANOTHER QUESTION YES
IS IT A VIOLATION OF THE
COMMERCE ACT TO HAVE CALIFORNIA
GO AFTER GLOBAL BUSINESSES. CAN
CAN YOUR COME AFTER CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES. PROFESSOR YES I AM
AND I MEAN LET ME JUST THAT HAVE
YOU CONCLUDED THEN WE'LL HAVE
HIM ANSWER THAT QUESTION AT THE
CLOSE IF THAT'S OKAY. YOUR. IF
YOU IF YOU WELL I'M I'M IN ASPEN
CENTER GROVE TO CONCLUDE AND
THAT WAY WE HAVE ALL THE
QUESTIONS AND YOU CAN ASK AND
ANSWER THEM IN YOUR CLOTHES WHAT
THE DIFFERENCE OF THE PRESIDENT
I'D LIKE TO HAVE THE QUESTION
ANSWER NOW SURVIVE A FURTHER
QUESTION I GET ASKED THAT IS
WILL BASED ON A RESPONSE THAT
HE'S GOING TO PROVIDE. THANK YOU
MA'AM. YOU MAKE YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU A MEMBERS IF I MAY
CLARIFY THE QUESTION DOES THE-
DOES THE CENTER FROM BAKERSFIELD
MEAN- COMMERCE CLAUSE OF THE
CONSTITUTION. YES OKAY- DANCERS
NO THIS DOES NOT VIOLATE THE
COMMERCE CLAUSE OF THE US
CONSTITUTION WE WORK WITH OUR
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL. TO MAKE
SURE. AND IN FACT THIS BILL.
FIRST OF ALL IT APPLIES TO
COMPANIES. THAT DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WE HAVE
JURISDICTION AS A RESULT. IF
THEY DON'T DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN A COVERED BY THIS
BILL- IN ADDITION THE BILL DOES
NOT REGULATE IN TERMS OF SAYING.
YOU MUST. DO X. Y. AND Z. OR
LOWER YOUR CARBON EMISSIONS. THE
BILL REQUIRES THE PRODUCTION OF
DATA. ITS INFORMATION. AND
PEOPLE CAN DO WITH THAT
INFORMATION. AS THEY WANT. THIS
IS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND MAKING
SURE THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS. TO
INFORMATION THAT'S WHAT THE BILL
DOES. THE INFORMATION IS VERY
VERY POWERFUL. THAT'S CERTAINLY
NOT A VIOLATION OF COMMERCE
CLAUSE. THANK YOU FOR THAT. I DO
AGREE THAT THE INFORMATION IS
VERY VERY POWERFUL BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT. FINING
BUSINESSES. FIFTY THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DAY
FOR NOT PROVIDING THIS
INFORMATION. IS AGAIN A FINING
AGAIN THE ANALYSIS IS FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION. FIRST OF.
GOVERNMENT. THAT WE NEED. A STEP
BACK IN LIEU AT HOW THESE GREEN
CLIMB GOALS ARE THAT. NO ONE IN
THIS BUILDING THE GUY HAS ME NO
BONES ABOUT IT WE'RE HE'S GOING
ON CLIMATE CHANGE. BUT IT JUST
UNFAIRLY TARGETS INDIVIDUALS WHO
DO BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
AND- TO DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE EMPLOYEE NOT
ONLY. INDIVIDUALS DIRECTLY WITH
THEIR COMPANY BUT HAVE THOUSANDS
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CONTRACTORS. THAT ARE MID LEVEL
BUSINESSES THAT PROVIDE JOBS TO
INDIVIDUALS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
AND I THINK THAT THIS WOULD BE
BETTER SUITED IN A FAIR JOB OF
FEDERAL JURISDICTION. SO I WOULD
RECOMMEND A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
SENATOR DOLLY I UNDERSTAND YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK AS WELL. YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN. AWESOME
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT- YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE LOOKED
OVER THIS BILL AND- I'M A
BUSINESS OWNER AND I'M
DEFINITELY NOT A BUSINESS OWNER
THAT- DOES GROW CELLS OF A
BILLION DOLLARS. BUT I'LLI WORK
AND LIVE IN THE STATE AND OUT
FOR A LONG TIME AND THIS BILL IS
JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE. OF
REGULATION YOU KNOW YESTERDAY
OUR PRESIDENT. WAS TALKING ABOUT
INFLATION AND THE WAS BLAMING
CORPORATIONS FOR INFLATION WELL
IN CALIFORNIA THE ONLY PEOPLE TO
BLAME FOR THE COST OF LIVING
GOING UP IS THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSING BILLS LIKE THIS ONE THAT
WILL COST. CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
MONEY A LOT OF MONEY TO GET THE
DATA AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO. PROVIDE THAT DATA YEAH THE
DATA IS SOMETHING WE- ALL ONE
HALF. BUT THAT'S THE REASON
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES ARE LEADING
WE LOST. TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX CORPORATE HEADQUARTERS LAST
YEAR THOSE CORPORATIONS PAY
TAXES IN THE STATE AND THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO COST THE
REVENUES TO DROP. S. AS THE
CENTER FROM SANTEE MENTIONED
ABOUT YOU ALL CAN'T GET ENOUGH
PEOPLE OF THE VEHICLES TO MOVE
PEOPLE OUT OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
BILL AND MANY OTHER BILLS THAT
ARE COMING FORWARD ABOUT CLIMATE
. WE NEED TO ANALYZE WE'RE
GIVING POWER TO THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD FOR GIVING
POWER. TO A LOT OF PEOPLE TO
MAKE DECISIONS. THAT ARE GOING
TO IN FACT CALIFORNIA. WHEN IN
FACT WE DON'T EVEN COUNT A LOT
OF THE CARBON. OPPORTUNITIES WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN WE GET SB THREE SIX THREE
FIFTY. A FEW YEARS BACK THEY
SAID WE WERE GOING TO COUNT.
LARGE HYDRO WHICH WE DON'T COUNT
WHICH IS CARBON NEUTRAL WE DON'T
COUNT NUCLEAR WHICH IS CARBON
NEUTRAL. THOSE ARE ALL THINGS WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING OUT WE TALK
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE THIS BILL
IS GONNA IMPACT BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S GONNA DRIVE THE
COST OF LIVING UP WHICH IS
ALREADY HIGHER THAN MOST PLACES
IN THE UNITED STATES. AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND I WISH I WAS THERE TODAY TO
BE ABLE TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
SENATOR BAKER. THANK YOU BUT MY
CAR IS A PRODUCT OF A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT I ARGUE ARE REALLY
TANGENTIAL TO THIS BILL IN THIS
BILL REALLY IS A- CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK. OKAY THIS BILL REALLY IS
A REPORTING AND TRANSPARENCY
BILL AND I FELT A RESPONSIBILITY
TO RISE BECAUSE TWENTY YEARS AGO
I WORKED FOR A SOFTWARE COMPANY
THAT MANAGES WILL SUPPLY CHAINS
FOR COMPANIES JUST THE BILL OF
MATERIALS CHANGE MANAGEMENT. AND
I GOT A CHANCE TO SEE THE SNOW
THEY KNOW THE SUPPLY CHAINS IN
IN INTIMATE DETAIL ACROSS THE
WORLD AND SO I JUST WANTED TO
RISE TO SAY THIS IS NOT IMPOSING
SOME GIANT NEW A BURDEN. ON
BUSINESSES THAT FOR EXAMPLE. I
WOULD TAKE ONE BUSINESS H. P. I
JUST LOOK THIS UP THEY COMMITTED
AT LAST EARTH DAY TO REACH NET
ZERO CARBON ACROSS THEIR VALUE
CHAIN. TWENTY OPERATIONS SUPPLY
CHAIN CUSTOMERS PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES BY TWENTY FORTY. CARBON
NEUTRALITY IN ZERO WASTE IN
THEIR H. P. OPERATIONS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. CARBON NEUTRALITY
IN H. P. SUPPLY BUSINESS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FINALLY ACHIEVED A
50% REDUCTION IN VALUE CHAIN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. SCOPE
ONE TO THREE BY TWENTY THIRTY
TWO BASE ONE TWENTY NINETEEN
EMISSIONS YOU CAN'T DO THAT
WITHOUT HAVING THE DATA. AND I
DID ANOTHER QUICK GOOGLE SEARCH.
THE CARBON- ACCOUNTING BUSINESS
ALREADY IS DIED ABOUT TEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO THE MARKET
FOR CARBON ACCOUNTING SOFTWARE
SO. THIS IS WELL UNDERSTOOD THIS
IS WELL UNDERWAY WALMART'S DOING
IT PERHAPS BECAUSE DOING IT
LEADING COMPANIES ARE DOING IT
WE TRY TO MAKE SURE THIS. HAT
THIS INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE
FOR ALL COMPANIES SO WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ALL THAT.
REALLY THE PRESSURES NOT TO COME
FROM GOVERNMENT IT'S GOING TO
COME FROM INVESTORS AND
CONSUMERS TO HELP. THESE
COMPANIES. HAVE MOVED TO AND
THAT'S YOUR FUTURE SO I JUST
WANT TO REMARK IT'S NOT IMPOSING
HUGE NEW BURDEN THIS IS WELL
UNDERSTOOD AND IT'S JUST REALLY
APPLYING IT. TOUCHES THE LEADING
EDGE COMPANIES TO REALLY ALL
COMPANIES OF THAT SIZE THANK YOU
. SENATOR NELSON. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
OF THE SENATE WILL WE EVER STOP
IN CALIFORNIA TRYING TO DRIVE
BUSINESSES OUT. THIS IS A
SCARLET LETTER BILL. IT'S A GOOD
WAY TO DESCRIBE IT. TO
DISCOURAGE BUSINESSES. TO ENTICE
BUSINESSES TO GO TO OTHER STATES
. HAVEN'T WE SEEN ENOUGH YET THE
BIGGEST OF THE BIG ARE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS NO LONGER
GOING TO BE THE HIGH TECH
HEADQUARTERS OF THE WORLD. IN
FACT IT SHOULDN'T EVEN BE NOW
BECAUSE OUR HIGH TECH STUFF IN
THE STATE NEVER WORKS. AT LEAST
AS IT IS APPLIED TO STATE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS AND
OPERATIONS. HAVE WE EVER HAD A
MAJOR MULTI BILLION DOLLAR HIGH
TECH APPLICATIONS THANK PHYS
CAL. THE HAS WORKED OVER DECADES
NOW. I THINK IT'S PRETTY SORRY
STORY. BUT THAT SAID WE'RE NOT
VOTING HERE TODAY ON THAT POINT
BUT WE'RE VOTING ON ANOTHER
SIGNAL TO THE WORLD NOT JUST
TEXAS. FLORIDA. SEVEN TAKE A
BUSINESSES. THEY'RE GOING TO GO
. JUST LAST TEST FOR. THEY SAID
FRIDAY. MANY MIGHT NOT HAVE READ
THAT. FAMOUS AND RAND BOOK ATLAS
SHRUGGED. BUT THAT WAS CAN SHRUG
. WHEN THE BURDEN GETS TOO HEAVY. I QUIT THE PRODUCERS QUIT AND
WE'RE TALKING HERE ABOUT THE
PRODUCERS. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CITIZENS OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS WHO WORK AT THESE
COMPANIES. THAT ARE BEING TOLD
WE DON'T WANT YOU. WE'RE GONNA
FRONT YOU OFF WE'RE GONNA SHINE
YOU. SUNDAY OUR GRANDCHILDREN.
WILL PAY THE PRICE IN FACT THEY
ALREADY ARE. FEB OR JUST. MMHM.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
BASIC SENATOR ALLEN WELL I MEAN
WITH WITH SO MUCH RESPECT TO OUR
COLLEAGUE THERE ARE CHILDREN.
PAYING THE PRICE IS EXACTLY WHY
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK ON A BILL
LIKE THIS ARE GIVEN THE SEVERITY
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS I JUST
HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
BASED ON SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT I MADE IS THAT- IF YOU
BECAUSE YOU AND I. DO NOT A
QUESTION. YOU WILL. SO IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AT THIS BILL.
IMPACTS OF THOSE COMPANIES THAT
DO BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA RATHER
THAN THOSE THAT ARE. THAT ARE
BASED IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN THE
CAUGHT SO WE IS THAT IS THAT
CORRECT. I'M THROUGH THE CHAIR-
YES THAT IS CORRECT THIS BILL
APPLIES TO COMPANIES TO DO
BUSINESS HERE. IT IS NOT LIMITED
TO COMPANIES THAT ARE
HEADQUARTERED HERE SO THIS IS
NOT A SITUATION WHERE. YOU BUY
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE THIS IS NOT A
SITUATION WHERE IF YOU DO A FAKE
MOVE LIKE TESLA DID. TESLA
DIDN'T REALLY MOVE. BABY
INCORPORATED OR MOVE THEIR
HEADQUARTERS TO TEXAS AND
EXPANDED THEIR OPERATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT MOVING YOUR
HEADQUARTERS WILL NOT GET YOU
OUT OF THIS BILL IF YOU'RE STILL
DOING BUSINESS HERE BECAUSE
TESLA IS STILL SELLING AN
ENORMOUS NUMBER OF CARS HERE.
AFTER WE SUBSIDIZE THE HECK OUT
OF THE COMPANY TO GET THEM WHERE
THEY ARE. TODAY SO THIS IS ABOUT
DOING BUSINESS HERE I DON'T
THINK THAT CHEVRON IS GOING TO
CLOSE ALL OF ITS GAS STATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
GOD FOR BID. PROVIDE DATA I
DON'T THINK AMAZON IS GOING TO
SHUT DOWN ALL OF ITS WAREHOUSES
AND DELIVERIES IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE SOME DATA I DON'T THINK
MOVERS GOING TO SHUT DOWN ITS
OPERATIONS. IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO PROVIDE
SOME DATA- DOES NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN IT'S ABOUT DOING BUSINESS
HERE. NOT BEING HEADQUARTERED
HERE. OKAY I'M OBVIOUSLY IF YOU
WERE TO FOCUS ON THOSE
HEADQUARTERED HERE I THINK
THEY'LL BE VERY PROBLEMATIC BUT
THE REASON WHY. I RESPECTFULLY
PUSH BACK ON SOME OF THE COMMON
MADE. AT CERTAINLY GONNA SUPPORT
THIS GIVEN THE SEVERITY THE
CLIMATE CRISIS AND THE NEED FOR
DATA COLLECTION. THERE'S NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR WHEN YOU MAY CONCLUDE I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOT A
PRESIDENT BECAUSE I DO
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST DEBATE AND
WE SHOULD BE HAVING ROBUST
DEBATE WHEN IT COMES TO CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THE EMERGENCY NEED
FOR CLIMATE ACTION I AGREE THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF PRESSURE IS
BEING PUT ON MIDDLE INCOME AND
LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND THE STATE
AND AROUND THE WORLD. AND WHAT
IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PRESSURE POINTS ON THEM.
IT'S NOT REQUIRING BILLION
DOLLAR COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
DATA. IT'S THE COST OF HOUSING
AND I THANK MY COLLEAGUES ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE WHO
SUPPORTED HOUSING POLICY. TO
MAKE IT AFFORDABLE FOR PEOPLE TO
LIVE HERE THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD HOUSING. AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE CLIMATE
CRISIS IS DOING TO PEOPLE IT'S
NOT THE RICH PEOPLE BUT IT'S
TURNING. ITS LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
MIDDLE INCOME PEOPLE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN FIRE ZONES AND HAVING
THEIR HOMES BURNED DOWN PEOPLE
WHO ARE SUBJECT TO FLOODING
BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN. LOW LYING
AREAS IN TOWN FOR TO MOVE UP
INTO THE HILLS. RETURNING PEOPLE
WHOSE KIDS ARE GETTING ASTHMA.
IT'S HURTING PEOPLE WHO LACK
ACCESS TO FOOD BECAUSE OF THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. ON
THE AGRICULTURAL SECTOR THAT IS
WHAT IS HURTING PEOPLE THE MOST
AND IT'S GOING TO ACCELERATE
OVER TIME. THIS BILL CALLING I
JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU ISABEL
TRANSPARENCY AND DATA THAT'S ALL
I'VE BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE MY
SIX YEAR NOW USUALLY DATA.
TRANSPARENCY BILLS FLY OFF OF
THIS WAR UNANIMOUSLY ARE CLOSE
TO UNANIMOUSLY. BECAUSE EVERYONE
AGREES HAVING MORE DATA AND
INFORMATION IS GOOD AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT FOR THE
MARKET TO WORK YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THAT TRANSPARENCY AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS WILL DO THIS WILL HELP
THE MARKET WORK I RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BAKER FIVE FORGES NO
BRADFORD. CABALLERO CORTELLI I
DODD DURACELL I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. WESTERN FURTADO.
JONES NO KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE
LEYVA AYE THE MOMENT AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ NO MAN. NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A CHAU VOTE. NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. RUBIO
SKINNER FIVE STERN FIVE I'M
BURKE AYE BY CAL SKI AYE WIENER
AYE WILK NO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD HAVE I
EVER. DODD GLAZER HERTZBERG WHEN
I HER TADO I. MEN ROTH. RUBIO.
FIVE TWENTY THREE NO NO SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS THIS
IS THE TIME FOR US TO TAKE OUR
LUNCH BREAK. WE WILL BE RETURNED
PROMPTLY AT ONE FIFTEEN THIS
AFTERNOON BUT BEFORE WE DO AS A
POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE- WISH A VERY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO OUR OWN
SENATOR NINA GONZALEZ. I
UNDERSTAND SHE HAS BIRTHDAY CAKE
IN OUR OFFICE SO. JUST KIDDING
WE CAN GET TOGETHER AND OFFICES
JUST KIDDING WE'LL SEE YOU ALL
AT ONE FIFTEEN THIS AFTERNOON.
WE'RE ON CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. AND WE ARE STILL ON
SENATE THIRD READING SO WE'D
LIKE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH IS SENATOR
MCGUIRE HE'S READY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY THREE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
RELATIVE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
CENTER MCGUIRE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. HOW MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT S. C. R.
FIFTY THREE IS A CRITICAL
RESOLUTION DECLARES A CLIMATE
EMERGENCY THAT THREATENS THE
STATE OUR NATION AND OUR PLAN I
DON'T KNOW I WANT TO SPEAK. S.
C. R. FIFTY THREE ALSO PROCLAIMS
THE GOLDEN STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
DOING EVERYTHING IN HIS POWER TO
COMBAT THIS GROWING CRISIS. I
KNEW ANALYSIS BY THE EUROPEAN
UNION'S CLIMATE CHANGE SERVICE
WHICH TRACKS GLOBAL TEMPERATURES
AND OTHER CLIMATE INDICATORS
FOUND THAT TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WAS THE FIFTH WARMEST YEAR ON
RECORD IN WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT
WESTERN STATES ARE MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO EXTREME DROUGHT
LARGER MORE DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IN OUR- COASTAL
COMMUNITIES ARE ALREADY
EXPECTING. ARE ALREADY
EXPERIENCING SEA LEVEL CHANGES.
WHILE WE IN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORICALLY LED THIS NATION ON
EMISSION REDUCTION EFFORTS NOW
MORE THAN EVER WE MUST REDOUBLE
OUR FOCUS TO COMBAT THIS CLIMATE
CRISIS IN DECLARE A CLIMATE
EMERGENCY WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR. AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. YES I WANT TO
SPEAK RUSSIAN OR DEBATE. SENATOR
DOLLY. CAN YOU HEAR ME MADAM
CHAIR WE CAN THANK YOU THE- THIS
RESOLUTION- I HAVE I HEARD IN-
EQ AND- I HAD SOME QUESTIONS
THAT I DIDN'T STILL GOT ANSWERED
VERY WELL LOOK THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT- WE'VE SEEN CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
HAVE THE ATTEMPTED TO BE A
LEADER IN. THE FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE MY QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR WOULD- DURING EACH
YOU WAS- THE I WANT TO I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE POLICIES WE HAVE
IN PLACE RIGHT NOW AND THOSE
WERE ADDRESSED ACTIVELY LOOKING
CALIFORNIA FLORIDA LEAD I THINK
WE REALLY NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
CARBON IN GENERAL- I DID A BILL
LAST YEAR- TO CAL CARBON FROM
FOREST FIRES WHICH CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY DOESN'T COUNT. THE
AMOUNT EMISSIONS THAT COME FROM
FOREST FIRES NOW WE CAN'T BERMAN
FROM- TRANSPORTATION. WE COUNT
CARBON FROM. ENERGY PRODUCTION
AND ALL THOSE THINGS BUT WE
DON'T COUNT. THE CARBON THAT IS-
SPEWED OUT IN FORCE FIRES WHICH
IS THE LARGEST. CARBON EMITTER
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD IN
SO. I THINK THAT THIS THIS
RESOLUTION IS GOING TO LEAD US
AYE AYE THERE WAS TALK DURING
EACH YEAR THAT. MAYBE WE SHOULD
HAVE A STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
THAT WOULD MEAN THAT TO. THE
GOVERNOR WOULD THEN BE IN
CONTROL JUST LIKE HE IS- HERE TO
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY WITH OUR
HEALTH CRISIS. IN FOR ME I THINK
THAT IS VERY DANGEROUS AND I
THINK THE POLICIES THAT COME OUT
OF A OF THIS HOUSE- IN THIS IN
THIS LEGISLATURE ARE. FLAWED
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
LAST YEAR HAD AN AUDIT IN THEY-
DETERMINED DURING THAT AUDIT
THAT- THEY WEREN'T DOING A GOOD
JOB OF SPENDING HAT. MONEY OF
CALIFORNIANS THROUGH. THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND WHAT WE WERE
GETTING FROM. ALL THESE POLICIES
IS DRIVING UP THE COST OF LIVING
IS DRIVING UP OUR ENERGY WE PAY
60% HIGHER ELECTRIC BILLS. THEN
ANYWAY MOST PLACES IN THE
NATION. AND THAT'S WHY PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY IN CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T COUNT- NUCLEAR IN. IN OUR
ENERGY AS AS A CARBON NEUTRAL WE
DON'T COUNT A LARGE HYDRO ONLY
THIRTY MEGAWATTS OF LAST. A
WIRED THOSE COUNTED AND WIRE
WIRE THOSE POLICIES NOT TALK
ABOUT WETALK ABOUT- YOU KNOW
DOING MORE FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
BUT IT DID BUT WHILE WE'RE DOING
REALLY IS WERE EXPORTING JOBS.
FROM CALIFORNIA TO COUNTRIES
LIKE CHINA THAT ARE. OR WHITE
FRANKLY BUILDING COAL FIRED
POWER PLANTS IT'S AS WE SPEAK
AND WE'RE BREATHING THAT AIR SO
I THINK THE POLICY IS WHAT WE
REALLY NEED TO TALK ABOUT NOT
JUST MAKING A STATEMENT AND IN.
MAKING PEOPLE. MORE FEARFUL
THAT'S REALLY LEAD IF WE'RE
GONNA LEADING CALIFORNIA'S
LEADING US LET'S DO SOME REAL
GOOD ENVIRONMENTAL WORK AND THAT
MEANS. LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT THE
FORCES TALK ABOUT A WATERSHED
JUST TALK ABOUT THE WILDLIFE
THAT IS IT DID DID DID
DESPERATELY NEEDS. TO BE LOOKED
AT NOT JUST STATING F. THIS
RESOLUTION IS SAYING HEY WE IT'S
A CLIMATE EMERGENCY YEP NO DOUBT
WHEN A CRIME IS NOT AN ALMOST A
MILLION ACRE FIRE. BUT WE DON'T
DO MUCH TO TALK ABOUT FIRES WERE
REGULATING LAWN MOWERS WEED
EATERS. AND GENERATORS WHICH WE
NEED BECAUSE WE ARE POWER
OUTAGES THAT'S THE STUFF THAT
JUST LEGISLATURE DOING IS WHAT'S
COSTS. CAUSING CALIFORNIA TO PAY
HIGHER IN BUILDING FEES HIGHER
IN. IN THE TRANSPORTATION COST.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S THE REALLY THE
PROBLEM HERE CALIFORNIA THAT'S
CAUSING INFLATION TO GO UP AND
IS THE RESULT OF THE LACK OF
THIS LEGISLATURE DOING REAL
GOOD. ENVIRONMENTAL WORK I'M
LOOKING FOR SOME ENVIRONMENTS
THAT REALLY CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT THE WANT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND NOT JUST.
REGULATE AND PUT FEAR INTO THE
PEOPLE LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
POLICIES. THAT COME OUT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THIS BILL THIS
BILL. IS- IS THIS GONNA DO MORE
HERE AND IT IS GOING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM. THE PROBLEMS ARE WE
HAVE A BULLET TRAIN. WE'RE
SPENDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
THAT IS NOT EVER GOING TO GET
OUR- CARBON REDUCED. ITS BECAUSE
SPECIAL INTERESTS IS RUNNING
THIS AND IT'S REALLY NOT ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT I PREFER TO BE
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT SHOULD
INCLUDE FORCE FIRE. YOUR CARBON
OUTPUT. SO FOR THOSE REASONS I'M
NOT GONNA BE SUPPORTING THIS
LEGISLATION. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ADAMS CENTER GROVE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WAS GOING
TO SPEAK ON THIS BUT I DO WANT
TO GO OVER SINCE. TOPICS BECAUSE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER BROUGHT
SOME STUFF UP. EARLIER I TALKED
ABOUT THE MOST REST THE COST OF
RUSHED TO GREEN AND TRANSITION.
IS ALREADY DISASTER BULL AND
DISASTROUS AND- DENIABLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE TALKED ABOUT-
HOMELESSNESS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BEAVER TALKED ABOUT THE COST OF
ENERGY THE COST OF FUEL AND ALL
OF THOSE THINGS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DON'T REALIZE IS
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
THE NUMBER ONE PURCHASER OF
ECUADORIAN OIL. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THEM THE OIL THAT'S PRODUCED IN
ECUADOR. IT'S AN ALTERNATIVE TO
LOCAL AND GAS PRODUCTION AND
IMPORTATION FROM FOREIGN
SOURCES. WE PRODUCE ENERGY
HEARING CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
IN KERN COUNTY OIL AND GAS
ENERGY. WHICH YOUR CALL YOUR
CONSTITUENTS MY CONSTITUENTS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COULD NOT
LIVE A COMFORTABLE OR A LIFE OF
COMFORT THAT WE HAVE NOW WITHOUT
THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY. AND WE
IT'S NOT THAT WE DON'T NEED OR
USE THE OIL AND GAS THAT IS
PRODUCED. WE JUST DON'T PRODUCE
IT IN OUR BACKYARD LIKE NIMBYISM
RIGHT WILL TEAR DOWN THE
ECUADORIAN RAIN STORES FOREST.
WILL FIND CHINESE CORPORATIONS
ON NATIONAL OIL THIS THE IMPORT
THAT BOYLE HERE TO CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS CAN
LIVE COMFORTABLE LIVES WHEN YOU
LOOK AT CALIFORNIA THAT BUYS ITS
VOCAL OR EXCUSE ME THE BULK OF
ITS OIL IMPORTS. WE RASHT-
POLICIES THAT ARE ENSURING THAT
CHINA. WHILE WE FINANCE THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE ENVIRONMENT
ACCELERATE GLOBAL CLIMATE
CHANGES AND GLOBAL WARMING. IN
ECUADOR IF YOU LOOK AT
PHOTOGRAPHS OR THINGS LIKE A
KERN COUNTY PRESENTATION OR
PHOTOGRAPHS FROM THE ECUADORIAN
RAINFOREST THE RIVERS THAT ARE
THERE. THE CHILDREN THAT ARE
LIKE TEN YEARS OLD COVER AND
COVERED IN OIL THE RIVERS
FLOODED WITH OIL WE ALLOW THAT
BECAUSE WE FIND THEIR OIL
PRODUCTION. I CAN TELL YOU
COLLEAGUES WERE WE YOU 70% OF
THE STATE'S OILING KERN COUNTY
WE DO NOT HAVE RIVERS FLOODED
WITH OIL WE DO NOT HAVE CHILDREN
BURIED IN OIL. A COVERED IN OIL
AS THEY WORK THROUGH THE OIL IN
THE ECUADORIAN CAN COUNTRIES I
CAN ALSO TELL YOU THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS AGAIN. CANNOT LIVE
WITH THE COMFORT AND
AFFORDABILITY WITHOUT THE OIL
AND NATURAL GAS THE GOVERNOR
KNOWS THAT WHEN HE THOUGHT THAT
THAT THE GROUP WAS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO. HELP HOLD WHAT WE WERE
USING IN CALIFORNIA HE
IMMEDIATELY DID AN EXECUTIVE IN
ORDER TO FIRE RIPS A FIVE
CALIFORNIA GAS PLANTS. HE
WOULDN'T DO THAT IF YOU DIDN'T
THINK THAT WE NEEDED IT WE HAVE
TO RELY ON OIL AND GAS- YOU GUYS
OF THE GIN MADE NO BONES ABOUT.
YOUR GOALS ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN
LOCAL OIL PRODUCTION YOUR BIG NO
BONES ABOUT THE GOALS THAT YOU
HAVE FOR CLIMATE CHANGE. BUT I
CAN TELL YOU THAT ALTHOUGH SOUND
REALLY GOOD IN AN ELECTION CYCLE
BUT ONCE THESE POLICIES PASSING
LOOK AT EIGHT OF YOUR
DESTRUCTION BY FOLLOWING. THIS
PEOPLE IN POVERTY. WILL NOT BE A
TO AFFORD THE POLICIES AND THE
COST OF LIVING WITHOUT THE OIL
AND GAS INDUSTRY AND I'M NOT
SAYING THAT EVERYTHING. AT THE
OIL AND GAS AND- SHE PAYS OR
EMPLOYEES PEOPLE I'M TALKING
ABOUT THINGS THAT WE USE EVERY
DAY FROM EVERY TIME YOU WAKE UP
IN THE MORNING AT TOUCHER ALARM
CLOCK TO THE BUTTONS ON MOST OF
YOUR GUISES SHIRTS. TO THE
GLASSES ON MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE FRIEND SAN FRANCISCO IT'S
ALL PETROLEUM BY PRODUCTS THOSE
DOES- CLEARS- BRACE THINGS TO
CORRECT YOUR TEETH. ALL HAVE A
PETROLEUM BY PRODUCTS MOST OF
THE STUFF THAT WE USE AND HOW
HOSPITAL'S PETROLEUM BY PRODUCTS
WITHOUT PETROLEUM INDUSTRY
PRODUCTS. THIS WOULD BE A THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY TAKE THE FIVE
POOREST COUNTRIES IN THE NATION
THEY HAVE NO PETROLEUM AND NO
OIL AND GAS. SO TO SET A GOAL
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A NON BINDING
RESOLUTION BUT TO SET A GOAL OF
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN THIS STATE
CAPITOL TO DESTROY AGAIN
NIMBYISM. YOU DON'T WANT TO
PRODUCE IT HERE UNDER THE
STRICTEST MOST ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY PRO LAWS IN THE MOST
EXTREME JUST LABOR LAWS IN THE
WORLD. BUT YOU LET THEM TEAR
DOWN THE RAINFOREST- YOU'LL LET
THEM TAKE AWAY INDIGENOUS
INDIANS- YOU KNOW THE AREA OF
SPACE THAT THEY LIVE IN JUST TO
GET THOSE SAME COMFORTS THAT YOU
ENJOY YOUR CONSTITUENTS ENJOY
EVERY DAY TO HAVE OIL BROUGHT
HERE ACROSS OUR ECOSYSTEM. IN
VESSELS THAT BUNKER FUEL THAT
PUT MORE CARBON EMISSIONS OUT
INTO THE AIR. ALMOST PROBABLY
EQUIVALENT TO OVER A PRETTY
DECENT WILDFIRE SO I WOULD JUST
ASK YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT
GLOBAL WARMING AND CLIMATE
CHANGE AND IT IS. EXACTLY WHAT
YOU THINK IT IS ABOUT YOU KNOW
DISASTROUS IT'S COMING THEN
LET'S ADDRESS IT FROM A GLOBAL
PERSPECTIVE AND USE THE MOST.
RELIABLE CHEAP RELIABLE ENERGY
THAT SAFE AND PRODUCED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BEFORE IMPORTING ALL
THESE- THESE PRODUCTS FROM THE
COUNTRY THE NUMBER ONE IS
HOSTILE AS HAS HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS THAT ARE DISMAL. AND
ALSO HAS A POOR ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO
THE- THIRTY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. THIS
EIGHT. THANK CENTER MCGUIRE YOU
MAKE THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
PRESS IN A GREAT FOR THIS COME
JUSTICE AYE AYE I MISS US BE
APOLOGISED TO BE AYE YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MA'AM AND I
WAS JUST TRYING TO GET OVER TO
MY NEED I CAN TO GET THE- I AM
REALLY COMES. IN THE WRESTLE.
WHILE LIKE WITH THIS. I BELIEVE
THAT'S A SPORT. BOB FEAR AT-
THERE SAID THE STAGE FOR THE
DUMB TO. DECLARE A STATEWIDE
CLIMATE. AND OUT WHO A LOT
ADDITIONALLY THERE POWER AND TRY
TO THE FIGHT AT ALSO QUOTE
EITHER ONE OF THOSE LATER CYBER
. AND I'M CERTAINLY ABOUT ANY
NOTION THAT A RESOLUTION PASSED
BY THIS LEGISLATURE COULD BE
INTERPRETED AS GRANTING THE
GOVERNOR NEW EXECUTIVE POWERS.
ARE I DON'T WANT. US ANYONE OF
OUR ACTIONS TO BE INTERPRETED AS
SENDING OUT STAGE FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO TAKE THE ANNUAL
UNILATERAL ACTION. BY THE NAME
OF CLIMB EMERGENCY AS WE ALL
KNOW THE POWERS OF THE GOVERNOR
ARE ESTABLISHED BY THE STATE
CONSTITUTION. AND ENHANCED
THROUGH STATUTE NOT THROUGH A
RESOLUTION. AND I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT WE HAVE HAD THE GOVERNOR
VERY INVOLVED WITH EXECUTIVE
POWERS DURING THE HEALTH. CRISIS
AND WE KNOW WHERE THAT HAS LED
OUT WE HAVE A DISTRUST OF THE
GOVERNMENT. I IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
SO TO TELL A TEAR IN GOVERNMENT
TOO MANY OF THE PEOPLE ARE YOUR
FRIENDS BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S
MAKING ALL THE DECISIONS BY
PASSING US. IN I DON'T THINK ANY
ONE OF US SHOULD AGREE THAT
THAT'S THE PROPER WAY TO GOVERN.
UNDER OUR CONSTITUTION SHOULD BE
OPERATING IN THIS JUST ABOUT THE
NEW STAGE FOR THAT. SO I WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT EVEN
THOUGH I DO SUPPORT. OF THE
SPIRIT OF IT I THINK WE'RE ALL
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE I MENTIONED THAT MY
DISTRICT SEES THE RISE. IF THERE
ARE WHAT ARE THE CAUSES THERE
ARE MANY THAT. WE REALLY NEED TO
HAVE THE LEGISLATURE INVOLVED WE
NEED TO BASE OUR DECISIONS ON
SCIENCE. IN NACHO ANECDOTES FROM
OUR- AREA SO GROUPS OF SUPPORT
FOR ANYTHING ABOUT CLIMATE- THEY
WANT. IMMEDIATELY TO REMOVE. YOU
KNOW EVERYTHING YOU KNOW DRUG I
GUESS GET US BACK TO LIVING ON
THE LAND IN DANCE THAT. ARE. I
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO VOTE FOR
TODAY AND IF IT GOES FORWARD
WILL CONTINUE MY OWN. THANK YOU
. ANY FURTHER TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE. SAYING NOW CENTERMAN I
THINK SOME IN A PRESS. I WANT TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT FACT
HERE. THE FACT IS RIGHT NOW. WE
ARE FACING A CLIMATE CRISIS. WE
CAN CONTINUE TO WRING OUR HANDS
WE CAN CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT IT
OR WE CAN ACTUALLY TAKE ACTION
AND- DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. SO
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO AND
WHAT THE GOVERNOR CAN DO. SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST. EVERYONE
KNOWS IN THIS CHAMBER WAS
SITTING HERE RIGHT NOW THIS.
RESOLUTION DOES NOT AFFECT. THE
GOVERNOR'S ABILITY TO ISSUE AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER. THE GOVERNOR
REGARDLESS OF THIS RESOLUTION
CAN ISSUE AN EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
THE CLIMATE CRISIS RIGHT NOW. WE
ALSO KNOW LET'S NOT PRETEND WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT IS WHAT
GUIDES THE GOVERNOR WHEN IT
COMES TO DECLARING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. SO IT'S HOGWASH THAT
THIS IS GOING TO EMPOWER THE
GOVERNOR. WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE. IS ON RECORD
BOTH WITH THIS RESOLUTION
INTERACTION SO LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE ACTION. OUR PRESIDENT PRO
TEM. OUR PRESIDENT PRO TEM IS
LEADING THE WAY WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE ACTION. HE'S BRINGING
TOGETHER A BROAD GROUP OF
SENATORS. TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
AN AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE ACTION.
POLICY AND BUDGET PLAN THIS
YEAR. SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THIS
ONE RESOLUTION IT'S NOT ABOUT
ONE RESOLUTIONS ABOUT COLLECTIVE
ACTION THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO TAKE. AND THE RIGHT
LEADERS IN THE RIGHT SEAT RIGHT
NOW AND THAT'S TONI ATKINS. AND
SHE'S GONNA BE ADVANCING ONE OF
THE BOLDEST CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN YEARS HERE IN
THE STATE CAPITAL. SO YOU WANT
TO SEE WHAT CHANGE LOOKS LIKE.
HANG ON. AND THE LAST THING I'M
GONNA SAY IT'S LET'S TALK ABOUT
THIS GOVERNOR AND WILDFIRE.
THERE IS NO WHETHER GOVERNOR.
REGARDLESS IF YOU AGREE WITH
THIS POLITICS OR NOT THERE IS NO
OTHER GOVERNOR. IN MODERN
HISTORY THAT IS INVESTED AS MUCH
AS GOVERNOR NEWSOM WHEN IT COMES
TO WILDFIRE RESILIENCE WHEN IT
COMES TO WILDFIRE RESPONSE AND
WHEN IT COMES TO PROACTIVE
ACTION LIKE. FOREST THINNING IN
WHEN IT COMES TO ISSUES OF A
WILDFIRE BREAKS. YOU DON'T HAVE
TO AGREE WITH HIM POLITICALLY
THAT'S JUST BE CANDID GO AND
LOOK AT THE FACTS. THE BUDGET IS
WHERE OUR VALUES ARE ACT. IN IF
WE VALUE THE FUTURE FOR OUR KIDS
AND WE HAVE TO COMBAT THIS
CLIMATE CRISIS. IN THE ONLY
PLACE BY THE WAY I'M GOING TO
SPEAK FOR MYSELF THE ONLY PLACE
WHERE THE CLIMATE EMERGENCY.
IT'S CONTROVERSIAL IS IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. YOU POLL PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE AND NATION
THEY'RE SCARED TO DEATH OF WHAT
THE FUTURE IS GOING TO MEAN FOR
THEIR KIDS BECAUSE OF THIS
CLIMATE CRISIS. SO WHAT I THINK
THAT WE ALL NEED TO DO IS WORK
TOGETHER AS WE ALWAYS HAVE IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY. TO COMBAT THIS
CRISIS BECAUSE THE CLOCK IS
TICKING. THE LIGHT IS REDDER
ALARM THE ALARM IS SOUNDING
RIGHT NOW SO WHAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK. IS FOR A AYE
VOTE ON FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
TO BE ADDED TO DECLARE A CLIMATE
EMERGENCY. AND LET'S GET THE
WORK DONE THIS YEAR TO COMBAT
THIS CRISIS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS FIVE BAKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO. I
PROTECTING FIVE DODD THERE ARE
SO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG.
QUESTION I FURTADO AYE JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA HI
LIMÓN HI MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO
MAN HI NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. NO A
TO A BOTH PAN HI PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER FIVE
STERN HI NUMBER I LIKE. HI
WIENER AYE WILK NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES DODD
HERTZBERG I JONES A CHOI BOGUE.
FIVE THIRTY KNOWS FOR THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FORTY TWO CENTER
PORTANTINO IS READY PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO DRINKING WATER
SENATOR PORTANTINO THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS SB TWO THIRTY THE
STATEWIDE CONSTITUENTS OF
EMERGING CONCERN IN DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM. WOULD REQUIRE THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD TO ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN
A DEDICATED CVC PROGRAM FOR FIVE
YEARS TO IMPROVE THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE OCCURRENCE
AND PUBLIC HEALTH SIGNIFICANCE
IN DRINKING WATER SOURCES.
CONSTITUENTS OF EMERGING CONCERN
OR CEC'S AS THEY ARE KNOWN OUR
DIVERSE GROUP OF SYNTHETIC OR
NATURALLY OCCURRING CHEMICALS OR
MICRO ORGANISMS THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY REGULATED IN DRINKING
WATER SCIENTISTS HAVE DISCOVERED
NEW WAYS TO DETECT THEM IN VERY
SMALL AMOUNTS USED TO BE THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT MEASURING CHEMICALS
IN PARTS PER MILLION. TEN PARTS
PER BILLION AND NOW WE CAN
DETECT DOWN TO PARTS FOR CHORE
PER TRILLION. GIVEN THIS
CAPABILITY SCIENTISTS WILL
CONTINUE TO DETECT NEW
UNREGULATED CHEMICALS THAT COULD
INCLUDE PHARMACEUTICALS PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS OR INDUSTRIAL
CHEMICALS IN TRACE AMOUNTS SB
TWO THIRTY IS THAT IS IT IS
DESIGNED TO HELP THE STATE WATER
BOARD GATHER INFORMATION TO
UNDERSTAND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
RISKS. OF THESE CHEMICALS AND
THEIR CURRENTS IN DRINKING WATER
SUPPLIES THIS INFORMATION WOULD
HELP THE STATE WATER BOARD MAKE
INFORMED SCIENCE BASED DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW TO PRIORITIZE AND FORM
REGULATION. THE BILL REQUIRES
THE STATE WATER BOARD TO CREATE
A SCIENCE ADVISORY PANEL MADE UP
OF EXPERTS TO ADVISE AND THEN TO
CREATE IN THE STATE TREASURY
ACTION FUND WHICH UPON
APPROPRIATION WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS.
THE BILL WAS AMENDED AFTER
PASSING OUT OF THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY- COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR TO MODIFY THE DURATION
OF THE PROGRAM TO FIVE YEARS AND
EXCLUDE P. FOSS FROM THE PROGRAM
OF REVIEW AND REQUIRE THE STATE
WATER BOARD TO PROVIDE A FINAL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE. MUCH
WORK IS BEING DONE AT THE STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVEL TO ADDRESS S.
P. FOSS AND I SHOULD THOSE
EFFORTS. THIS IS A CLASS OF
CHEMICALS FOUND. IN CONSUMER
COMMERCIAL AD INDUSTRIAL
PROJECTS PRODUCTS PRODUCTS SOME
OF WHICH ARE KNOWN TO BE HARMFUL
AND HAVE HARMFUL HEALTH EFFECTS.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAM NUNN
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. SAYING NINE THIRTY
SEVEN FIVE KNOWS ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO ITEM FILE
ITEM NUMBER FORTY THREE SENATOR
SKINNER. HE'S READY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO PEOPLE MEALS CENTER SKINNER
FOR HIS EARS THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I THINK- WE
REALIZE AND IT'S A TRAGEDY THAT
30% OF CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN
EXPERIENCE HUNGER WE MADE BIG
PROGRESS ON THAT LAST YEAR WHEN
WE PASSED. THE TO FREEZE MEALS
AT SCHOOL FOR EVERYONE OF OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOL CHILDREN. SB THREE
SIXTY FOUR PICKS UP ON THAT END
IT INSURES THAT WHEN SCHOOL IS
OUT OF SESSION OR CLOSED THAT
CHILDREN ALSO THOSE WHO NEED IT
CAN HAVE SOME ACCESS TO FOOD
SORRY CREATES THE BETTER OUT OF
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAM. AND IT
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA TO MAXIMIZE
OUR FEDERAL PANDEMIC EBT
BENEFITS DURING WHEN SCHOOLS ARE
CLOSED DUE TO COBIT AND PROVIDES
NEEDED FIXES TO DATA COLLECTION
POLICIES. AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE SIR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATE
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR PRESIDENT AS A- CO AUTHOR OF
WHATEVER HECK I AM OF THIS BILL
I JUST WANT TO- RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT YOU KNOW SOME YEARS AGO
WE DID A LUNCH SHAMING BILL IN
THE SECOND LUNCH SHAMING BILL.
AND I JUST THINK THAT AS WE FACE
THESE EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES
SOCIETY. THE KINDS OF BURDENS
THAT ARE FACED BY CHILDREN- AND
YOU HEAR THE STORIES OF KIM KIDS
GOING TO SCHOOL AND THEY CAN'T
STUDY BECAUSE IT. IS THE HUNGRY-
ARE JUST UNBELIEVABLE AND SO I
JUST WANT TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT
TO STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
THINK THAT IS WE DEBATE SO MANY
ISSUES ON THIS FLOOR AND WE TALK
ABOUT EDUCATION SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IS JUST
ONE OF THOSE STRONG PILLARS UPON
WHICH WE NEED TO STAND. TO
SUPPORT THE NEXT GENERATION TO
MAKE SURE THEY GET A FULL
STOMACH SO THEY CAN STUDY AND
LEARN HAVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY
THAT EVERYBODY EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE I STAND
STRONG SUPPORT AS FOR AN IPHONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE I ALSO STANDIN
STRONG SUPPORT I REALLY WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR RIGHT NOW-
YOU KNOW JUST GETTING TO KNOW
HER ALL THESE YEARS I KNOW THAT
EDUCATION OUR CHILDREN ARE
ALWAYS FIRST IN FIRST FOREMOST
IN HER MIND AND JUST KNOWING
WHAT I WITNESSES A TEACHER FROM
KANSAS JUST NOT BE ABLE TO
PERFORM BECAUSE THEY'RE HUNGRY
OR TALKING ABOUT STARTING THE
NIGHT FOR NOT HAVING HAD
ANYTHING TO EAT AND TELL THE
STORIES ARE VERY COMPELLING TO
ME I'M SPECIALLY. BEING A
TEACHER HAVING TO BUY FOOD FOR
THEM I KNOW THE NEED IS GREAT
AND THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HELP ITS HOSTILE ONE OUT
STRONGLY AMERICAN IDOL IN STAND
AS A STRONG WATER THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR TO. SEAMEN
CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY CONCLUDE
THANK YOU ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- GIVE ME
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
. SEEING NO OBJECTION I THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FORTY FOUR SENATOR
WIENER IS READY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR SIXTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO TRIAL TESTIMONY CENTER WIENER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO RESIGN AS BEFORE SIXTY
SEVENTY AND WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS
OCT. BY THIS BILL CLARIFIES IT
EXPERT OPINIONS OF VALUES VALID
METHODOLOGY RESEARCH PEER
REVIEWED STUDIES WERE
SCIENTIFICALLY SOUND DATA DO NOT
SATISFY THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
ADMISSIBLE EXPERT TESTIMONY- THE
BILL ALSO- VOWED TO EXPAND THE-DEFINITION OF FALSE TESTIMONY TO
INCLUDE OPINIONS. BASED ON
FLAWED SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
ELEVATED TECHNOLOGY AND DISPUTED
QUOTE UNQUOTE SCIENTIFIC
OPINIONS. FINALLY THE BILL WILL
HELP PROVIDE POST CONVICTION
RELIEF FOR ANYONE WHO WAS
CONVICTED USING EXPERT TESTIMONY
BUT RELIED ON FLAWED SCIENCE
RESEARCH WHEN SOMEONE IS
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED OF A CRIME-
IS A HORRIBLE MISCARRIAGE OF
JUSTICE- IT MEANS THAT AN
INNOCENT PERSON IS IMPRISONED.
AND THE PERSON WHO ACTUALLY
COMMITTED THE CRIME- IS ON FILE
HI IN SOCIETY- TODAY OUR COURTS
HAVE- DISCRETION OVER WHICH
EXPERT TESTIMONY IS ADMISSIBLE.
HOWEVER STUDIES SHOW THE COURTS
TYPICALLY ACCEPT MOST FORENSIC
SCIENCE AND EXPERT TESTIMONY
WITH L. MUCH SCRUTINY LEAVING
SIGNIFICANT ROOM FOR LACK OF
PRECISION AND FRANKLY FOR HUMAN
ARE- THIS LEADS TO AN
UNACCEPTABLY. HIGH RATE OF FRAUD
CONVICTION. CUSTOMER THE FELL
THROUGH ON LOGIC AND- SHE NOT BE
IN IN COURT. I WOULD THAT
FRIENDS ARE SCIENCE A LEE CAUSE
. OF OUR- SIGNS OF MENTAL CAUSE
OF WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS- AND WE
HAVE A CHANCE TO REALLY TACKLE
THAT ISSUE TODAY. EXPERT
OPINIONS COLLEAGUES WE KNOW CAN
BE EXTREMELY PERSUASIVE AND
INFLUENTIAL IN THE OUTCOME OF A
TRIAL AND ONCE THE JUDGE ALLOWS
TESTIMONY AND- IT'S VERY VERY
HARD TO OVERCOME IT EVEN IF IT
IS DEEPLY. FLAWED THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES- TO ASSISTED
AND STATED THAT A SIGNIFICANT
PART OF THIS PROBLEM AS WE YOU
PROBABLY HEARD IS THE SO CALLED
CSI- FACT WERE JURORS HAVE AN
UNREALISTIC AND PRECONCEIVED
NOTION. ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY
OF PRECISION OF FORENSIC
EVIDENCE IN CRIMINAL TRIALS. SB
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN WILL HAVE
EXONERATE INNOCENT PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND IT WILL PROVIDE
JUDGES WITH STRONGER TOOLS AND
GUARDRAILS I TO MAKE SURE THE
FLAWED SCIENCE DOES NOT MAKE ITS
WAY INTO THE COURT ROOM. S.
FRONT I'VE- THREE. EIGHT ZERO.
SENATOR I'M SORRY. THAT A PRESS
JONES SENATE I URGE A NO VOTE.
WHEN WILL A THIS EVER BE. NOW
WE'RE TO HIGH TO EXPERTS. EXPERT
FOR MOST RECENT STUDIES. WHETHER
OR NOT THEY HAVE VALIDITY OR
CREDIBILITY OR PEERREVIEW OR
WHATEVER. BASED ON ALLEGATIONS.
THESE ARE JUST MORE ATTEMPTS TO
BE ROLLED THE JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
ENSURE THAT JUSTICE FOR THE
VICTIMS OF CRIMES DO NOT SEE
JUSTICE DONE. THAT INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES HAVE
MORE VENUES TO ESCAPE ANY
CONSEQUENCES FOR THEIR BEHAVIORS
. IT SEEMS LIKE WE ARE ALMOST
EXHAUSTED WILL QUEST. TO HAVE
NOBODY DO ANYTHING WRONG. WHY
DON'T WE JUST GET RID OF OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE COURT SHUT HIM
DOWN. HEATHER BE NO PENALTIES
AND NO CRIME BOISE HOW GREAT IS
WORKED OUT REALIGNED. WONDERFUL
THE DUMBING DOWN OF CRIME ACROSS
AMERICA. LOOK AT AMERICA'S
CITIES UPON CITIES AND WHAT'S
GOING ON WITHIN THOSE CITIES
RIGHT NOW IS JUST AMERICA FOR
THE FUTURE FOR OUR CHILDREN I
THINK NOT AND THERE'S MORE OF
THESE INCREMENTAL BILLS. THAT
ARE COMING THE TRIM AROUND THE
EDGES TO GIVE THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS MORE TOOLS. THE GET
INDIVIDUALS MEANS AND WAYS TO
BEAT THE RAP. WE HAVE A VERY
PERFECT AND PERFECTED THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN AMERICA.
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED. WE HAVE
MANY VENUES FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO SEE JUST REMEDY.
IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME AND
THANK GOD SHE DOES BECAUSE THERE
ARE ERRORS. BUT NOT NEAR AS MANY
AS SOME TALENT RIGHT NOW. YOU
KNOW FOR A WHILE A FEW YEARS WE
WENT THROUGH THIS. TREND OR THE
FAD ALL DIMINISH IT EVEN TO CALL
IT A FAD. WE WILL GET BACK TO
TOUGH ON CRIME. WELL DURING
THOSE YEARS OF QUOTE TO TOUGH ON
CRIME IN THE MINDS OF SOME.
WHERE WE SAY FOR. AARON BUCKLEY
UNEQUIVOCALLY ABSOLUTELY. WAS
JUSTICE DONE IN THOSE RARE
INSTANCES WERE JUSTICE DID NOT
OCCUR YOU BET. WE CAN CALL OUT
THE INSTANCES. I REGION NO VOTE
ON ALMOST ALL OF THESE BILLS
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN IT'S TIME
TO SAY ENOUGH JUSTICE FOR
CONVICTED CRIMINALS AND MORE
JUSTICE FOR A LAW ABIDING SIX
CITIZENS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
SENATOR KAMLAGER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I AM RISE AND
URGENT I VOTE ON S. B. FOUR SIX
SEVEN I WASN'T REALLY PLANNING
TO SAY ANYTHING BUT- AFTER
LISTENING TO SOME OF THE COMMON
SPELLED- COMPELLED- YOU KNOW.
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM IS NOT
PERFECT. B. IT IS INCREDIBLY
FLAWED BECAUSE OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM WAS DESIGNED AND IS RUN
BY PEOPLE. AND PEOPLE ARE FLAWED
AND THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY NOT
TO TURN AROUND THE EDGES BUT TO
REALLY INJECT. SOME FAIRNESS- AN
OBJECTIVE THINKING ABOUT
TESTIMONY AND ABOUT INFORMATION
THAT IS SHARED WITH JURORS
DURING TRIALS AND HOW THAT
INFORMATION IS SHARED AND OFTEN
TIMES IT IS SHARED BY FOLKS WHO
ARE LOOSELY TERMED EXPERTS THIS
BILL IS A NOT IT IS NOT ABOUT
CRIMES THE BILL IS NOT ABOUT
CRIMINALS IT IS NOT ABOUT PEOPLE
DOING STUFF THAT'S BAD. IT'S
ABOUT PROCESS AND IT'S ABOUT
TESTIMONY. AND SO MANY FOLKS CAN
FIND THEIR WAY. INTO A TRIAL IN
FRONT OF A JURY WITH THAT TITLE
EXPERT. LAUDING SOME KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT IS FLAWED THAT
IS SUBJECTIVE. AND THAT IS HARD
TO VERIFY. BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS
WHEN YOU COME BEFORE A JURY
JURORS. WITH PARTICULAR TITLES.
WHEN IT COMES A LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THE KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE
PRESENTING. AND WHEN YOU'RE
DISCUSSING WHETHER OR NOT TO
SEND SOMEONE SOMEONE AWAY. FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME OR FOR LIFE
. IT'S PROBABLY A GOOD THING. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE FOLKS WHO ARE
TESTIFYING IN PROVIDING
INFORMATION ARE PROVIDING
ACCURATE VERIFIABLE. INFORMATION
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY YOU ARE
DECIDING IF SOMEONE IS GOING TO
GO AWAY FOR LIFE. VERY LONG TIME
OR NOT. THAT IS WHAT THIS BLL
SAYS AND ONCE AGAIN I JUST
IMPLORE US TO CONSIDER THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM. AND IT IS A
BATTLE BETWEEN SIDES OFFERING
INFORMATION AND NARRATIVE. ABOUT. YOU SHOULD REALLY MAKE SURE
THAT THE INFORMATION THAT YOU
ARE PRESENTING IS TRUE. AND IS
NOT CLOUDED BY TITLES AND FALSE
INFORMATION THAT IS NOT WHAT WE
WANT OUR COURTS TO REPRESENT SO
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AS BEFORE SIX SEVEN.
SENATOR BRIDGES. THIS IS AN
INTERESTING ISSUE. THE COUPLE OF
POPULAR COMMENTS. THE BEEN
AROUND FOR A LONG TIME. THAT
EVEN A HAM SANDWICH COULD BE
INDICTED. AND IF YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR AN EXPERT TO SERVE AS AN
EXPERT WITNESS. SKY'S THE LIMIT
YOU CAN GET ANYBODY TO SAY
VIRTUALLY ANYTHING. IT IS
ACTUALLY TRUE THE SYSTEM IS
PRONE TO BUY AN OPINION- TYPE OF
SCENARIO WE'VE SEEN IT WE KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS. BUT I THINK WE
ALSO HAVE A FLIP SIDE OF THIS
COIN I THINK THE AUTHOR IS
TRYING TO REMEDY SOMETHING IS
MERITORIOUS. IS THAT WE WANT TO
BRING. A GREATER SCRUTINY
GREATER CREDENTIALS GREATER
QUALIFICATIONS IN THE ASSESSMENT
OF ALL THAT THAT GOES INTO
WHETHER OR NOT SOMEONE SHOULD BE
DEEMED AN EXPERT. I WOULD
CAUTION MY COLLEAGUES HOWEVER
THAT THERE COULD BE A SERIOUS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE HERE. AND
THAT WOULD BE THE CREATION OF
COTTAGE INDUSTRY. TO ABSOLUTELY
CREATE COUNTER SCIENCE
DELIBERATELY TODAY WHEN YOU DO
HAVE SOMEBODY OUR WHO IS
PRESENTING ON MATERIAL BASED ON
SCIENCE OR DATA THAT THERE IS A
BODY OF SCHOLARSHIP OUT THERE
THAT CAN BE USED PRECISELY FOR
THE PURPOSE OF. UNDERMINING IT.
THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS
SITUATION THAT FRANKLY COULD BE
AS DANGEROUS IT'S THE SITUATION
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW. I APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING ON THIS
THIS IS A- THIS PROJECT THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. BUT I
DON'T SEE HOW IT'S GOING TO
RESOLVE WHAT IS INHERENTLY
UNRESOLVABLE WHICH IS THE JURY
OR THE JUDGE HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO DETERMINE THE
WEIGHT. AN EXPERT OPINION HAS ON
THE BEARING AN OUTCOME OF THE
CASE. THAT IS THE ESSENCE OF OUR
SYSTEM. SAME WAY IT IS WITH
SOMEONE WHO IS A PROPOSED
WITNESS. THEY WEIGHED THE MERITS
AND IN CIRCUMSTANCES OF THAT
OPINION OR THAT OBSERVATION. I
DON'T THINK THERE'S A WAY OUT OF
IT- RUSSIAN REGRETFULLY I'M
GONNA HAVE TO- NOT SUPPORT THIS
TODAY BUT I THINK WHAT HE'S
TRYING WITH WITH THE OTHERS
TRYING TO DO HAS MERIT. BUT I
THINK THAT THERE IS A MORE
NATURAL WAY THAT IT CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED IN THAT WOULD BE A
SET OF EXPECTATIONS AND
PROTOCOLS PROBABLY BETTER VETTED
THROUGH. THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AND OTHER AGENCIES AND
INSTRUMENTS- WITHIN- WITHIN THE
PRACTICE OF LAW INCLUDING THE
BEER THE BAR ASSOCIATIONS ON
WHAT ARE CONSIDERED. ACCEPTABLE
CREDENTIALS BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN
THAT- WHEN PEOPLE PRESENT
THEMSELVES AS EXPERTS OFTENTIMES
THEY ARE EXPERTS FOR HIRE.
SENATOR A. THANK YOU AMEND
PRESIDENTIAL- I ONCE KNEW A
PROSECUTOR WHO ULTIMATELY BECAME
A DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN IS PRO
LIFE SERVED ACTUALLY IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IN ANOTHER CHAMBER.
WHO WAS OVERHEARD SAYING ONCE
ANY MEDIOCRE PROSECUTOR CAN
CONVERT CONVICTED INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS GUILTY. IT TAKES A GREAT
PROSECUTOR TO CONVICT SOMEONE
WHO IS NOT. AND THIS MEASURES
SIMPLY PUTS. EXPERT WITNESS
TESTIMONY ON THE SAME FOOTING IS
TESTIMONY OF PERCIPIENT FACT
BASED WITNESSES WHO TESTIFY IN
TRIAL. AND WE'RE THERE ARE
DEFECTS IN THAT TESTIMONY OF ONE
SORT OR ANOTHER. WHETHER IT'S A
FACT WITNESS OR AN EXPERT
WITNESS DEFECTS THAT ARE
DISCOVERED POST TRIAL. THAT THE
CASE IS REVIEWED. BY A COURT.
AND IN APPROPRIATE CASES JUSTICE
IS DONE. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
PROCESS IS ALL ABOUT. IT'S NOT
PROSECUTING THOSE IN CONVICTING
THOSE WHO ARE NOT GUILTY. WHERE
THERE ARE PROSECUTING THOSE
WHERE THERE IS SOME QUESTION AND
DOING THINGS IN IN PRESENTING
TESTIMONY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE CONVICTED EVEN THOUGH THEY
MAY NOT BE. IT IS MAKING SURE
THAT THE PROCESS IS FAIR. AND
THE JUSTICES STYLE. AND IF
EXPERT TESTIMONY IS LATER
DISCOVERED TO BE BASED ON FLAWED
SCIENCE. TESTIMONY THAT IS
INACCURATE DELIBERATELY SO OR
PERHAPS NOT. THE COURT HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THOSE
CASES TO MAKE SURE THAT INNOCENT
PEOPLE. CONTRARY TO MY
PROSECUTOR FRIEND ARE NOT
CONVICTED I SUGGEST AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE. THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING NINE SENATOR WIENER YOU
MAKING. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT BECAUSE I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL-
ACTIVITY ON THIS BILL HERE WE
HAVE A LOT OF FIGHTS- ON THE
SENATE FLOOR IN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE- ABOUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE ON BILLS ABOUT WHAT
SHOULD BE A CRIME OR NOT A
CRIME. WHY SHOULD THE SENTENCE
BE- AND SO ON AND SO FORTH AND
THOSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCES AND WE
HAVE THOSE FIGHTS WE TAKE THOSE
VOTES AND SOMETIMES AS MEASURES
PASS AND THEN THEY DON'T. HI
THIS IS NOT ONE OF THOSE FIGHTS
AND THAT THERE'S A REASON WHY
THIS BILL. LITERALLY RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. IN
BOTH OF THE COMMITTEES THAT WAS
HEARD IN. THIS BILL LITERALLY
HAS NO OPPOSITION. NOT THE TA IS
NOT ANY OF THOSE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OF NOTHING NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. BECAUSE THIS IS A BILL
WHOSE TIME HAS COME. IN THIS
BILL IT WOULD BE CLEAR THOSE TWO
THINGS. IT GIVES JUDGES STRONGER
TOOLS TAKE TO PREVENT JUNK
SCIENCE FROM COMING INTO OUR
COURTROOMS. I LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RIVERSIDE AND LIKE OUR
COLLEAGUE MARIN COUNTY WHO IS-
STILL- DOING LAWYER WORK- AS
WELL I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DO
BOTH BUT OUR GOD BLESS YOU- BUT
I MIGHT HAVE A SLIGHT BEFORE I
WAS IN ELECTED OFFICE I SPENT
FIFTEEN YEARS AS- AS A ATTORNEY
AS A LITIGATOR I DID JURY
TRIALS. ON AND I'LL TELL YOU AND
ANYONE WHO IS PRACTICE AND ON
TRIALS WILL KNOW THAT THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN SOMEONE PUTSAN
EXPERT ON THE STAND AND YOU SAID
YOURSELF HELL ON EARTH. IS THIS
PERSON TESTIFYING. HELL ON EARTH
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT THIS PERSON
IS FACING A POWERFUL OPINIONS
BECAUSE THE JURY'S JUST REALLY
MOST OF IT HERE THE BOTTOM LINE
OPINION IT'S SO POWERFUL. AND
YOU REALIZE THAT IS BASED TRULY
ON JUNK. AND SOMETIMES IT'S
BECAUSE- FIFTY YEARS AGO. THE
CALIFORNIA COURT OF APPEAL.
DECIDED THAT ACCESS KIND OF ACTS
FOR WITNESSING WAS APPROPRIATE.
AND EVEN THOUGH THERE'S BEEN
ENORMOUS SCIENCES SINCE AND THAT
HAS SHOWN. THAT IT IS REALLY
DUBIOUS COURTS JUST KEEP LETTING
IT AND LETTING IT END. BECAUSE
OF WHAT HAPPENED YEARS AGO WE'VE
SEEN THIS WITH. MICRO HAIR
ANALYSIS RECEITA WITH
FINGERPRINTING ANALYSIS THAT
OVER TIME NEW SCIENCE COMES OUT.
AND YET THESE THIS TESTIMONY
JUST KEEPS COMING IN. AND THIS
SIMPLY STRENGTHENS THE GUARD
RAILS. TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
KIND OF JUNK SCIENCE WERE REALLY
DEEPLY DISPUTED SCIENCE DOES NOT
OVERWHELM. ON A JURY. AND TO BE
CLEAR. WHAT THIS ISN'T ABOUT
WHETHER RELATING CRIMINALS GET
OUT OF JAIL FREE. THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT IF WE CAN PICK
SOMEONE IT'S ACTUALLY THE PERSON
WHO DID IT THE ONE INNOCENT
PERSON GOES TO JAIL. NOT ONLY
DOES NOT DESTROY THE LIFE OF
THAT INDIVIDUAL AND THEIR FAMILY
HOW IS THAT FAIR TO THE VICTIM.
THE PERSON WHO ACTUALLY
COMMITTED THE CRIME IS NOT THE
ONE WHO WENT TO JAIL THAT
DOESN'T HELP THE VICTIMS THAT'S
IT INSULT. TO THE VICTIM. SO THE
WE NEED TO REALLY FOCUS THAT
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT AND IF
SOMEONE GETS HIDEOUS CORPUS
BECAUSE OF THIS AND- CONVICTIONS
OVERTURNED BECAUSE IT WAS BASED
ON JUNK SCIENCE. THEY'RE NOT
AUTOMATICALLY FREE THEY'RE GONNA
GET RETRIED. AND THE PROSECUTION
WILL HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL DO IT THE
RIGHT WAY AND IF I CAN'T DO IT
THE RIGHT WAY. MAYBE IT'S
BECAUSE A PERSON'S ANDERSON
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BAKER. I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE FOR
TESTING AYE DODD THEY'RE AWESOME
I EGGMAN HI GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HUESO
HYPER TANTO. JONES. KAMLAGER I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA HI LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ. MANY AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN NO CONTROL
BOTH I PAN. FIVE PORTANTINO I
ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
HI I'M BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE
SPEAKER AYE WIENER AYE WILK NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN I DODD GROWTH HER TADO.
JONES MELENDEZ. IS THIRTY KNOWS
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
SENATOR SKINNER IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIX
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR SKINNER AN
ACT RELATING TO CALFRESH CENTER
SKINNER THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB
SIX FOUR ONE ALSO DEALS WITH
HUNGER THIS TIME WITH OUR
COLLEGE STUDENTS WE FOUND THAT
CALIFORNIA SHE IS A VERY AFFECT
TOOL TO HELP. WHAT STUDENTS KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE ISSUE N. S. SIX ONE
INCREASES COLLEGE STUDENTS
ACCESS TO CALFRESH. BY CODIFYING
ARE PUTTING INTO STATUTES SOME
OF THE REGULATIONS THAT CAME
FROM THE COLLEGE HUNGER WORKING
GROUP. AND REQUIRING OUR
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
ADJUST THE CALIBRATION
APPLICATION PROCESS SO THAT WE
CAN ACCOMMODATE THE VERY LARGE
NUMBER OF APPLICANTS THAT COME
IN AT THE START OF THE COLLEGE
SCHOOL YEAR. IN LASTLY IT ASKS
THEM TO DO TO GIVE US SOME
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
WHAT OTHER WAYS WE MIGHT. BE
ABLE TO INCREASE THE ACCESS OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO CALFRESH AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SAYING NINE THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE THIRTY SEVEN EYES
NOSE ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON THEIR FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN SENATOR ALAN.
CALLING ON SENATOR ALAN. HE IS
READY PLEASE READ SENATE BILL
FIVE SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR
ALAN AN ACT RELATING TO
EDUCATION FINANCE. SENATOR ALAN
THE FLOOR IS YOURS WELL GOOD
MORNING AT. GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
VETR PRESIDENT- SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL IT HAS TO DO WITH
SCHOOL FUNDING- THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS HAD A
MASSIVE IMPACT ON EVERY FACET OF
OUR LIVES AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN THE LAST TWO YEARS OUR
SCHOOLS THE PIVOTED FROM VIRTUAL
LEARNING TO HYBRID LEARNING
THEIR FACES SHIFTING BUFFET
SITTING ROMAN STOPPING SHORTAGES
I KNOW THAT MY DISTRICT MANY OF
MY SCHOOL DISTRICTS OF. CONCERNS
THAT ENROLLMENT WILL CONTINUE TO
SHIP. PREDICTABLE WASTE.
IMPACTING THEIR FUNDING EVEN AS
THEY RESPOND TO INCREASE STUDENT
NEEDS. I KNOW THAT OUR
COLLEAGUE. FROM MY CAN YOU HAD A
HAS A BILL GOING TO READ SHIFT
THE ENTIRE. WAY THAT WE FINANCE
OUR SCHOOLS BUT IN THE MEANTIME.
ARE WE HAVE AN ISSUE. WE'VE SEEN
ENORMOUS VOLATILITY ENROLLMENT.
IN THIS BILL WOULD HELP TO
CREATE SOME STABILITY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE FACED WITH-
WITH WITH WITH THAT WITH A GREAT
DEAL OF ONE OF NORTH. SO THE
BILL FREE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ABA
FOR TO SHOW YEAR AS WE CONTINUE
BROADER DISCUSSIONS ON WHAT
SCHOOL FUNDING LOOKS LIKE IN THE
FUTURE. PROVIDING THIS MUCH
NEEDED CERTAINTY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AS THEY PLAN THEIR
SPENDING THEIR STAFFING THEIR
PROGRAMS AHEAD OF THE BOT BUDGET
ADOPTION I SERVED ON MY LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD. I DURING THAT THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT DOWNTURN IT
WAS IT A TERRIBLE YOU KNOW VERY
DIFFICULT EXPERIENCE THEY'RE
GOING THROUGH. SOMETHING THAT'S
MUCH MUCH WORSE BECAUSE OF ALL
THE- ALL THE POLITICS ALL THE
OTHER COULD BE ISSUES BUT ALSO
THE IN MARIN ROMAN VOLATILITY.
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEED THIS
MEMBERS- I- YEAH MA'AM IT'S AN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SURE
THE SUPPLIES THE CURRENT YEAR
FUNDING AS WELL. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. MA'AM IS
THERE ANY. OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING US SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS- I SAW
THIS BILL AND- EDUCATION AND I
HAVE A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR IF
I MAY WOULD YOU ACCEPT A
QUESTION CENTER ALLEN YES OF
COURSE HE WILL. EVEN PRESENTED
ALI. THANK YOU BUT YOU KNOW. I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD WORD OUR
THIRD YEAR NOW THAT- I THINK
IT'S THIRD YEAR THAT WE'VE JUST.
BASICALLY TAKEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THAT WAS AVAILABLE AT THE TIME-
PRE COATED IN AND KEPT THAT.
TOWARDS OUT BUT QUITE FRANKLY.
WELL THAT'S A REWARDING STE
WALDRON PENALIZING OTHERS AND
MANY OF THE- REASONS THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE EXITED. THE WE OF
LOWER AND RIGHT IS BECAUSE
POLICIES NEEDED OUT OF THE
SCHOOL BOARD OR OR- OR A AREAS
WERE. TWENTY TO TAKE THEIR KIDS
AND THAT THOSE REPORTS DONE
THROUGH CODE IN SO HERE WE ARE
IN THE THIRD YEAR AND SOME OF
THOSE SCHOOLS SOME PEOPLE MOVE
THEIR KIDS SAYS SCHOOLS WERE
OPEN OR FOR VARIOUS REASONS TRY
TO ACCESS TO SCHOOLS TO GO TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE PLACES WHERE
THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET. A SERVICE
SO CONTINUE TO JUST- BLAKE IN
THE FUN SCHOOLS THE SCHOOL'S
ATHLETIC KIDS QUITE FRANKLY- AND
WE HAVE INFUSED A LOT OF
RESOURCES BUT THE SCHOOLS THAT
AT GREW UP QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE
THE POLICIES THAT THE THEY'RE
GETTING PENALIZED BECAUSE
THEY'RE EIGHTY IS ACTUALLY. YEAH
AT WHERE WE WERE BEFORE SO WHAT
WE DO YOU INTEND TO DO TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES. WELL
SENATOR REID THROUGH THROUGH THE
PRESIDENT- WE ACTUALLY HAVE
ADDRESS THAT CONCERN THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE. ALSO WE'VE APPLIED
OUR THE LEGISLATION TO THEM AND
TO THE CURRENT YEAR- ANOTHER SEE
THERE'S MORE MONEY IN THE SYSTEM
FOR EVERYONE THANKFULLY- BUT IN
THE END OF THE DAY WE RECOGNIZE
SO ALL THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
ARE TAKING IN MORE STUDENTS FOR
WHATEVER. REASON WE'LL WE'LL GET
MORE MONEY ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
NEW STUDENTS. BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT BECAUSE OF THE
EXTREME VOLATILITY ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS TOTALLY UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION. OUT WE WANT TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE. STRUGGLING
TO BALANCE THEIR BUDGETS ARE
GIVEN ALL THE ROAD VOLATILITY
SO. IT ONLY STANDS A FOR ONE
ADDITIONAL YEAR WE KNOW HOW
UNPRECEDENTED THIS MOMENT IS. I
JUST THINK THAT THE- I JUST
THINK THAT THE MOMENT REALLY
CALLS FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS-
YOUR FOR YOUR P. COULD I
REMEMBER OUR OUR DIALOGUE IN IN
IN IN COMMITTEE. SENATOR AND WE
GOT WE GOT THAT THAT ISSUE
ADDRESSED. IN APPROPRIATIONS
IMMENSE- BUT BUT BUT YOU'RE
PROBABLY SPEAKING. HI THIS IS
JUST ABOUT ENSURING THAT DURING
THIS UNPRECEDENTED MOMENT ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE ABLE TO.
HIDE HERE TO KEEP THEIR BUDGETS
BALANCED. AND KEEP YOUR LIGHTS
ON KEEP THEIR- KEEP THEIR THEIR
THEIR OPERATIONS GOING. UNTIL WE
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF WHERE. OF
HOW WE'RE GOING TO EMERGE BUT AS
WE DISCUSSED AND EDUCATION
COMMITTEE I THINK THE COMMITTEE
NEED TO TAKE UP. THE BROADER
QUESTION OF THE OF WHERE WE'RE
GOING POST COVETED IN ROMANCE
AT. SCHOOL FINANCING OF THOSE
ARE ALL BIG QUESTIONS THAT NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED IN IN THE
COMEDIAN AND THE SUB AND- BUT
ALL THIS BILL DOES IS THIS KEEP
KEEP. KEEP THEM HOLE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR GIVEN ALL OF
THE- VOLATILITY. I THANK YOU FOR
THAT COMMENT. I WOULD JUST
SUGGEST THAT. REDUCE ANALYSIS ON
WHERE THESE KIDS ARE GOING AND
WHY THE PARENTS ARE CHOOSING- TO
TRY TO GET THEIR KIDS EDUCATED
IN DIFFERENT PLACES THAN WHERE
THEY HAVE THEY HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY AND YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE TAKING GREAT STRIDES
TO. A PENALIZED SAID CHARTER
SCHOOLS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AND I THINK- AT LEAST IN
MY DISTRICT AND- PROVOKES I'M
HEARING- ACROSS THE STATE THAT.
THEY WANT SOME MORE OPTIONS AND
THEY WANT THEIR MONEY TO BE ABLE
TO FOLLOW THEIR CHILDREN TO
SCHOOLS THAT THEY CHOOSE- IN IN
THIS BASICALLY IS CONTINUE TO
KICK THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD AND
ALLOW SCHOOLS TO. CONTINUE TO
GET FIND. OUT WHEN THEIR
STUDENTS AREN'T THERE AND SO WE
NEED TO THOSE ISSUES BUT NOT
FOR. AND NOT. WE MAY BE IN THE
PANDEMIC FOR SOME LONGER BUT BUT
THE OVER ISSUE IS WHY OUR KIDS
ARE. AND WHY ARE PARENTS
CHOOSING OTHER OPTIONS AND THE
MONEY'S NOT ON THOSE KIDS
WETHERBY CHARTERS OR WHATEVER-
ABILITY THEY WANT PARENTS WANT
TO HAVE A FOR THEIR TAX DOLLARS
TO GO OVER THEIR KIDS ARE GOING.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THING AND-
SENATOR GLAZERS.
THE COMPUTER.
THANK YOU OF MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IT'S WANTED TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED BY
THE SENATOR FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I WAS IN SENATE
EDUCATION WE HEARD THIS BILL AND
I WANT TO SAY THAT THE CONCERNS
THAT HE EXPRESSED AND I JOIN HIM
EXPRESSING HAVE BEEN MET BY THE
AUTHOR IN THIS LEGISLATION AS
AMENDED. THAT IT TREATS SAY
PROVIDES THAT EQUITY INDEX
ACROSS SCHOOL DISTRICTS BOTH
PUBLIC CHARTER AND PUBLIC SCHOOL
AND I THINK FOR THOSE REASONS UP
THE BILL IS DESERVING OF SUPPORT
TODAY AN ERA CAN I THOUGHT. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN SENATOR ALLEN YOU MAY
CONCLUDE JEFF THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR WINNING
IN THANK YOU ALSO TO OUR
EDUCATION CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
INTERPRETATIONS CHAIR I YOU KNOW
I THINK YOU THINK THAT YOU'RE
THE ISSUES RAISED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER- CERTAINLY
MERIT SOME DISCUSSION. BROADLY
SPEAKING AS WE FIGURE OUT WHERE
WE'RE GOING POST A POST POST
COVERED BY YOUR THERE'S DID BUT
BUT THE TRUTH THE MATTER HIS
MEMBERS THAT BOTH THOSE SCHOOLS
THAT FOLKS ARE ARE TURNING TO
THE SENATOR ALLUDED TO THEY WILL
GET THE FUNDING BECAUSE- THAT
THAT THAT THEY NEED TO SPEAK TO
GROW AND OUR DISTRICT UNDER THIS
BILL WILL CONTINUE TO GET
FUNDING AND THEN AS WE GO INTO
THE NEXT YEAR WE'RE FIGURE OUT
HOW THIS OLD SCHOOL FINANCING
SYSTEM. I WILL THE POST CODE
I'VE GOT THAT STRING WE'RE ALL
GOING TO BE ENGAGED IN AS A
GROUP BUT THIS IS SOMETHING IT'S
GOOD IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
STOPGAP MEASURE FOR A DISTRICTS.
FOR THE TIME BEING AND WITH THAT
IN THAT SPIRIT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ADVICE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BAKER.
I FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE PARTISI AYE DODD.
THEY'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN I
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG AYE WESTERN. I FURTADO
I JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA FIVE LIMON AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN AYE A CHOI BOGUE I PAN.
HI PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE NUMBER FIVE
WHAT CASTING AYE WIENER AYE WILK
. I. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO GET READY TO LIFT THE
CALL SO IF YOU COULD GO BACK TO
YOUR SEATS AND BE PREPARED.
WE'RE GONNA LET THE CALLS ON-
THERE ARE THREE ITEMS. FILE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX. S. C. A. TWO
BY SENATOR ALAN. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. DODD EGGMAN I NIELSEN. I
RUBIO I. THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT SB
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE I SENATOR
GLAZERS. FOR JUST PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FORGES DODD RUBIO HI.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE. S. C.
A. FIVE BY SENATOR GLAZER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. DODD RUBIO. I.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR MELENDEZ.
SENATOR MELENDEZ YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE TWENTY EIGHT I MAKING A
MOTION TO WITHDRAW ESSERE FIVE
FROM THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE AND WE
BROUGHT TO THE SENATE FLOOR SO
THAT WE MAY HAVE A FULL AND
VIGOROUS DEBATE ABOUT THE
CONTINUED MERITS OF THE GOVERNOR
STATE OF EMERGENCY. IT HAS BEEN
NOT. ONE HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED
THREE HUNDRED FOUR HUNDRED FIVE
HUNDRED IS BEEN SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR DAYS. SINCE THE
GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY FOR KEVIN NINETEEN
FOUR HUNDRED AND TEN DAYS SINCE
I ORIGINALLY. INTRODUCED LEASH
LEGISLATION TO END IT. I THINK
IT IS- TIME SIX SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR DAYS IS A LONG TIME I THINK
IT IS TIME THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REASSERT ITSELF ONCE AGAIN AND
STOP SUBORDINATING THIS BODY TO
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THURMOND THANK
YOU SO MUCH TRYING TO PRESENT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVA. VERY
GOOD SENATOR MCGUIRE AFTER A NO
VOTE SENATOR MELENDEZ US FOR AN
AYE VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN NOW ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO
BACKER NO FORGES. I BRADFORD NO
CUT BY ADAM NO CORTESE NO DODD.
THE RAZA NO EGGMAN. NO GLAZER.
GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ. NO GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG NO QUESTION. IN THE
MIDDLE. HUESO NO HER TADO NO
JONES I KAMLAGER. NO LAYERED NO
LEYVA NO LIMON NO MCGUIRE. NO
MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION NO NEWMAN
NO NIELSEN. I A CHOI BOGUE HI
PAM. NO PORTANTINO NO BRA NO
RUBIO. NO SKINNER NO STERN NO
NUMBER NO WAY CASKEY. NO WIENER
. NO WILK. I NO THIRTY FIVE
SEVEN KNOWS THIRTY THE MEASURE
THE MOTION FAILS. UNDER SENATOR-
BURGESS. FOR WHAT PURPOSE THE
RICHMOND RESIDENT- IN THE
INITIALLY WOULD BE A POINT A
POINT OF ORDER- MAYBE I CAN YOU
CAN HELP ME UNDERSTAND- IF THIS
WAS NOT LAID ON THE TABLE AND
WENT DIRECTLY TO A VOTE DID THAT
NOT CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO DEBATE IN HAVE AN OPTION
TO DISCUSS. OKAY OKAY SENATOR
COULD YOU TELL US WHAT THE POINT
OF ORDER WAS SPECIFICALLY BY
ROPE. IT WOULD BE A AN IN KOREA
TO ALLOW FOR DEBATE PROCEDURALLY
BECAUSE WAS NOT LAID ON THE
TABLE IF THAT'S THE ACCURATE WAY
OF STATING IT AND I WOULD ASK.
FOR ANY SPECIFIC LANGUAGE FROM-
HOUSE LEADERSHIP. THE CENTER
BRIDGES MY UNDERSTANDING IS THIS
IS A PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY. IS
THAT DETERMINATIVE. THAT THAT'S
WHAT WHAT IT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR IS A PARLIAMENTARY
INQUIRY FOR PURPOSES OF
PROCEDURE. YES. OKAY IS THAT AN
ACCURATE MOTION TO MAKE THAT
INQUIRY. HEY YOU'RE ENQUIRING IS
EXACTLY WHAT. MY RECOLLECTION I
COULD COULD BE MISTAKEN MY
RECOLLECTION WAS THAT
PREVIOUSLY- THERE WAS A MOTION
TWO LADIES ARE THIS TYPE OF ITEM
WHICH YOU'VE HEARD. MANY MANY
TIMES ON THE TABLE THIS WENT
STRAIGHT TO A VOTE HOWEVER.
ACCORDING TO THE DESIGN RIGHT-
OKAY. YEAH THAT'S ALL. YEAH SIX
SAN BRIDGES THE- THE MOST WAS TO
REMOVE THE THAT THE ITEM FROM
COMMITTEE AND- BE THERE THE ONLY
DEBATE THAT YOU CAN HAVE ON THAT
ITEM IS A PROPRIETY OF. AT OF
WHETHER THERE'S A NEED FOR A
ROBUST DEBATE. SO THERE'S NO
THERE WAS NO NEED. FOR ANY OF
THE OTHER PROCESSES THAT YOU
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT OKAY THANK
YOU FOR ANSWER MY QUESTION THANK
YOU. MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON WE
ARE UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. WHAT ARE ASK YOU IF
YOU HAVE A BILL THAT IN THE AN
IT REMOVED FROM THE AN ACTIVE
FILE THIS IS YOUR LAST
OPPORTUNITY IS OR ANYBODY THAT
HAS A BILL IN THE AN ACTIVE FILE
. THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO MOVE.
SING SING NOW NO ONE WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO. WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
GONNA WAIT WHERE CAN MOVE ON TO
THE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY SENATOR
BAKER. I CAN SK YOU ALL THE HAD
TO TAKE A SEAT. SO WE CAN LISTEN%
RESPECTFULLY TO THIS ADJOURN IN
MEMORY. I WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE IT SENATOR BAKER THE
FOUR IS YOURS. THANK YOU COLLEGE
TODAY RISE TO JOIN MEMORY
PACKAGE DO YOU HAVE PASSED
THROUGH ON SEPTEMBER TENTH.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY ONE. FORTY CONNECTICUT ON
OCTOBER NINETEENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE PACKED WITH THE CITY
OF SUNNYVALE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE. AS FOR THE NEXT FIVE
DECADES. THANK YOU ESTABLISH AN
UNMATCHED LEGACY IN THE
COMMUNITY. I THINK IT SHOULD BE
COUNTLESS HOURS TO LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS SHE RAN WAS
ELECTED CITY BILL CITY COUNCIL
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND
DINNER TENURE SHE WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND TO THE
BOARD OF THE NATIONAL LEAGUE OF
CITIES. AFTER COMPLETING HER
TENURE. IF YOU COULD JUST AS
MAYOR SHE CONTINUE BE VERY
INVOLVED THE SAME VOTE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. THE HERITAGE MUSEUM
AND OTHER GROUPS. SHE WAS ALWAYS
INCREDIBLY GENEROUS WITH HER
TIME MENTORING IN ADVISING MANY
MANY GENERATIONS OF SUNNYVALE
AND LOCAL LEADERS. AND MORE
SERVICE LAST YEAR'S INCREDIBLE
THE NUMBER OF PAST AND CURRENT
LECTORS WHO SHARED STORIES OF
HER MENTORSHIP AND HOW SHE
HELPED THEM. WHEN I WAS FIRST
CONSIDERING RUNNING FOR THIS
OFFICE MY PREDECESSOR CENTER
CHERRY HILL. GIVE ME A LIST OF
COMMUNITY LEADERS TO MEET WITH.
PAT WAS. ONE OF OUR VERY SHORT
LIST AND SHE WAS ALWAYS VERY
GENEROUS WITH HER TIME. WITH ME
AND I ALWAYS DEEPLY APPRECIATED
THAT. SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND CARLOS FIVE CHILDREN
CARLOTTA JAMES CHRISTOPHER
ANTHONY INTERNET. EIGHT GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN MR A GRANDCHILDREN
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND FRIENDS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN
MEMORY OF A GREAT LEADER
PATRICIA ALAN CRISTEA. PLEASE
BRING HER NAME TO THE DEATH SO
THAT SHE MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMBER MEMORIALIZED BY THE
SENATE. MEMBERS IF THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS
THE DESK IT'S CLEAR. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY THAT'S TOMORROW
THURSDAY THE TWENTY SEVENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT NINE AM
THANK YOU. MEMBERS THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED WE WERE OVER RECONVENE
TOMORROW THURSDAY AT NINE AM.